do you need your microphone
Center
I believe that we are recording
this um I am Jeffrey saloway it is
um October 3rd and I am calling to order
uh the subcommittee meeting on Precision
Medicine subcommittee of the oversight
committee uh on Health and Human
Services
um
and uh
if I had a clerk I would ask the clerk
to call the roll
however uh seeing that representative
gay is present and representative Canon
is present and representative Merchant
is present and representative Woods is
present and I of course representative
salary and present we can assume that
the role has been called I am not
confident that we have a quorum
but uh I think we have enough to at
least begin our discussion
um representative yes if I may I did see
that counselor John Williams ex officio
has been on the subcommittee as well is
that true
at least it's on the list here
uh oh yes of course if he is I would
invite him to join us at the table
please counselor Williams will you
please join us at the table we don't
want you to feel left out
you can sit up here with the big boys
well thank you thank you very much but
for uh total transparency and
clarification uh originally I had work
in um uh with the uh formation group on
this particular
um uh subcommittee for the HHS oversight
committee so originally I was tagged
with ex-officio working with this group
however my recollection and I just can't
bring up my uh internet computer right
now but I believe that represent Pearson
did make a final selection of course um
approving the appointment of
Representative Jeffrey soloway as the
chair of the committee I don't believe I
made the final cut for this group
however at one o'clock this afternoon I
am I've been uh appointed as a member
along with also a counterpart at the
office of professional licensure and
certification uh Douglas osterhout for
the afternoon meeting regarding
transparency issues on the board of
medicine so thank I'm in the audience of
course we're here as a resource to the
committee and I also have with me today
just for the record uh we have the
wonderful uh Peg Clifford she's a
Medicaid pharmacist she's the director
of that area and we are here to take
careful note and attention perhaps we
may be invited as guests to come up to
provide information on this important
issue as it relates to Medicaid thank
you thank you
um
is uh there is a preliminary document on
Precision medicine which has been
circulated numbers of times in the
oversight committee is there anyone who
does not have a copy or who would like a
copy
you have everybody has that uh
representative you have that okay okay
it's the same one it's endless
um and the
um membership of the committee has been
updated on my computer I haven't yet
updated it on this document but I
promise I will get that done
okay
um we have
a number of questions that drive us and
uh I'm going to just give you a a
brief entree uh by the way ladies and
gentlemen I would suggest that we keep
this meeting briefs given the
temperature
and I sincerely regret that sincerely
however
um so uh representative Catherine Rogers
of treasured memory uh came before the
um
house committee the house committee on
Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs and proposed legislation on
Precision medicine and asked the
committee the house committee to begin
the process of uh entering into
consideration of legislation the
chairman uh representative Pearson
exercised his prerogative to remand that
process to the oversight committee on
Health and Human Services because that
was a way of Expediting the work of the
subcommittee and that went to the
oversight committee the oversight
committee voted to approve a
subcommittee to look into Precision
medicine and representative Pearson
selected members of that subcommittee
and you are here to today
um
in the process of bringing the proposal
before the oversight committee the
document on Precision medicine which you
have before you was drafted
I must say it was drafted with very
careful review by the members of that
initial subcommittee and it was
um
amended considerably my deathless prose
was uh
uh edited uh with a butcher knife
so
um the task force uh was given
um the uh challenge to study and make
recommendations to the legislature to
support improved awareness understanding
and access to Precision medicine and
biomarker testing by Patients health
care providers employ
excuse me
saloway here
I representative
Jennifer's office hello
do you understand
do you have heat in the State House
uh
not toasty but it's probably warmer than
do you have any idea what your
temperature is
temperature is because if you're not
much higher than we are we'll just
continue our deliberations
well I I was calling to let you know
that the Senate uh can accommodate your
meeting in State House from 100 I have
not been down there so I don't know what
the environment is but I do have heat
coming out of my
leader of my office
actually for somewhat better shape than
you consider yourself privileged
I I think what we will
end up
of ESU as a
only able to be resolved by the
department of administrative services
and our staff has been on them
for self-solved but for whatever reason
it hasn't been resolved I was on
vacation
with all due respect I think what I'd
like to do is to let this meeting go on
for another 25 minutes 11 o'clock where
we are rather than moving and taking the
time to do that and we will then
um
reschedule our meetings for something
other than Mondays
all cooler times mode
folks who control those systems haven't
fully done that yet okay with my partial
understanding okay well thank you for
the help in better shape
okay I will ask the representatives in
attendance to stop breaking up the
furniture and dropping matches on the
wood
okay
okay thank you for your help bye-bye
uh with your kind permission I would
suggest that uh we meet for another 25
minutes and call it a day
um and I'm hoping that by this afternoon
things will have warmed up so
um you have on page two of this document
a number of
tasks
for the subcommittee
taking a look at definitions of
biomarker testing review of studies on
the current status and I've had
conversations with representative Woods
in this regard and I'm hoping that he
will share his wisdom with us and you
have the rest of the uh
uh directives to the task force in I
think in front of you
so
um I I wonder if
perhaps representative woods and
representatives Merchant
could give us
just a brief few words on their own
areas of expertise and their own point
of view
just for a matter of a few minutes
before we adjourn promptly at 11 o'clock
by all means representative okay
I had intended
obviously you you know representative
gay that our first obligation is to
listen to testimony from the public
that we that they are our constituents
however the public has not shown up
um and
um therefore we can go forward with our
deliberations but as a general operating
principle
um I give preference to the public
so given that we are here
and I have not by the way appointed a
clerk at this point and I think I'm
going to serve as my own clerk for the
moment
um and given the problem of temperature
I would say let's begin our
deliberations
take What notes we can
and reschedule
alone
our disability hope for an hour and a
chance
My Hope was to go to noon
um
but if we take the time to move over
we'll lose 20 minutes and I just want to
if
best determined by me and the goal of
this subcommittee is to look at
introducing legislation for next year
correct yes sir
so
in reviewing the goals that were
outlined on page two is it really
fundamentally for this committee not
to do the work of the task force but to
ensure we have the framework for
legislation to create the task work to
get the work done
we need to well we are the task force
we're it but so if we're doing the work
of the task force then why do we need
legislation are we trying I'm trying to
get to is well we we are sequentially
supposed to investigate to determine
if legislation is needed okay
and our recommendation will be to the
oversight committee suggesting yes we
need legislation in these areas I
understood thank you
did you want to speak okay yeah I I
think
following up on reps of gay
it would be critical for us at least for
myself to hear from the experts out in
the field I mean I have my own knowledge
base along with many of us here
but it's going to be a snapshot or a
small part of a very long continuum so I
think trying to round out future
meetings if we can is to as much as
possible
ask those out in the audience to come
prepare to provide us with testimony
about why we need to have the
legislation as well
um we have president with us
um
uh Peg Clifford from Medicaid
what I think has a great deal to offer
would you want to hear from her first
I think she has a lot to offer I don't
take for a long time she's very much
knowledgeable in this area because of
Medicaid and things she does but I also
think we need to hear from the
providers themselves as well as the
pharmacy community and also I think we
can reach out to miss menahan to the
hospital community and find out what's
available within that around many of
these are going to be providers I think
one of the constraints with providers is
of course patient care they're they're
busy like all of us and it's trying to
find a doc at a time so we can publish
the times going forth that people can
try to free up the time to be your from
patient care
uh
Ms Clifford Miss minahan
would you wish to present testimony at
this time
yeah
I'm sorry a little louder
okay
so I was not planning on testifying
today but I'd be happy to do so at a
future meeting excellent thank you let
me ask the same question of Ms minnehan
representing the hospital Association
good morning everyone Paula Monahan
Hospital Association um yes I've been
working
um actually reached out to a cancer
specialist at Wentworth Douglas who Dr
soloway excuse me representative soloway
is aware and I believe doc Dr
arula
mahadivan will is willing and able to
participate in the task force I just I
don't think he was just able to
participate today but he's very
interested in this so I think you're
right representative Merchant we do need
specialists in this area because this is
a very specialized area and I would
defer to um to
um Dr mahadivan from the cancer center
at the Seacoast Cancer Center at
Wentworth Douglas but I hope hopefully
he can come at a future meeting I also
know the medical society had a couple
individuals that were also interested in
in testifying so I think and I believe
believe you have two more meetings
scheduled so normally yes I believe so
hopefully one of those meetings we could
have someone from the medical society
have their representative as well but I
agree that it would be really helpful to
also have like you said the pharmacists
um speak as well to this because it's
just so it's just such an important and
specialized area that they would I mean
I know have interest as well thank you
you're welcome Mr chair are we bound
by certain rules in other words can we
as a subcommittee have testimony done
remotely I'm just thinking about the
provider's time so they can talk to us
remotely versus being here in person
I thank you for the question I had
assumed that we would be on Zoom it
turns out that we do not use zoom we use
another uh product
that uh broadcast out but I don't
believe broadcast back in so we will
have to find out how to do that I've
been in contact with Christina Dyer who
is normally our staff person however she
is out with covet it was that kind of
week last week
um so thank you for your patience so
um
what we can't do is record votes coming
in over media the voting has to be here
but I believe that we can receive
testimony and I would certainly want to
do that if I can add parenthetically I
have lined up
three other people to testify I'll go
over that just briefly one of them is uh
Dr Joseph drabic he is just recently
chief of Hematology Oncology at Penn
State Medical Center in Hershey and he
comes from a research perspective
he's very very well published researcher
the other person is also from
Pennsylvania Dr Leah cream
she is an oncologist
and has won a clinical oncologist of the
Year award Awards in Pennsylvania
trained at Dartmouth Hitchcock and she
represents a patient point of view she
is very much a clinician the third
person that I have lined up is a former
CFO of an organization a private
organization
entrepreneurial organization which
markets individual testing genetic
testing
and that person
um
has some insights into the nature of
organizations that do this kind of uh
testing uh who they charge how they get
reimbursed and what happens to the money
so I have those three lined up and we'll
try to get that done over Zoom
okay
um that said
um I believe you have indicated
representative Merchant that you would
prefer a longer period of time to
testify is that correct rather than
speaking today
yes thank you
um representative Woods
um I just was going to make a couple of
you asked for a couple of comments I
said I would be uh brief and I would be
non-academic definition of brief
he defined act being brief academically
meant he could at 45 minutes
I said I could be brief very brief and
less than 45 minutes I can do that
anytime uh Mr chair so uh your your call
uh I I must tell you I I believe that uh
representative gay and others have uh
come here today and I would like to
accomplish something and I I must say
I'm most anxious to hear your comments
and I have some questions for you uh
after your comments if that's okay
that's perfectly fine okay so um
uh I'm noted for uh trying to look at
things from the 30 000 foot perspective
uh but also uh I'll offer that my
perspective is one with my physics
background and graduate work in
biophysics and molecular dynamics of
maintained some interest in some of the
work that's in the Nano field and and
precision field
looking at the overall my my perspective
is that a Precision medicine is just a
March in the development of medicine my
great great grandfather was a
self-taught horseback doctor in the
plains of Texas
no hospitals
and then they built these structures
called hospitals and probably put him
out of business
and we've developed from there from
Physicians then we decided that we
needed someone to do the specialty
cutting so we've got you know
Physicians and surgeons and and now we
have
4721 I picked a number
specialist surgeons uh and each of those
uh like I say I'm a repeating surgeon um
but I
specialize rather than just surgery
Orthopedics but I do upper extremity and
more specialized I do hand surgery and
jokingly say I only do the left hand
right hand is much too complicated
um but that so what we're looking at
from my perspective is the natural March
of medicine and what we are as a society
the science is really outstripped our
ability to appreciate and understand and
properly apply the technology and what
we're doing here is struggling to try
and figure out you know what is the best
way to apply it and apply it directly
and appropriately
and we've seen in the past what we have
not done so well
an example in this legislature
was a bone marrow transplants for breast
cancer
there was a huge human cry
that this was the thing to do
and in fact it won the day and this body
passed legislation saying that insurance
companies had to pay for it
well within six months of Passage it
found that in fact the people that were
naysayers were correct that in fact
there was no role for bone marrow
transplants and breast cancer treatment
before that there is the Leia Trill
those of you old enough to remember the
leotril Fiasco a cancer treatment and
how could you deny these poor kids
treatment I can go to Mexico and get it
for 10 bucks and we can't get it here
well then it turns out within another
six months found out that wasn't the
thing to do either
so we're struggling and in fact we're
not doing so well at times
so I view this
body this committee as to one of their
roles is to look at what we're asking is
it appropriate and which ones or
individual ones are appropriate or not
and then we can ask ourselves uh it's
available how can we make it accessible
and of course availability does not
equal accessible
and that's where the pinch is going to
come
technologically it can be very complex
and I give the example of
the one that we saw early on
probably the earliest of misuse of
Technology you may recall
when splitting the atom was discovered
oh my goodness look at this we can split
the atom
and look at all the energy we can get
out of that we can we can run all kinds
of things with all this energy
well some dark person decided you know
what I can make a bomb out of this too
and we're still struggling with the dark
side of that discovery
so we as we progress along we want to
ask ourselves you know what are the
downsides of what we're doing
one of the next biggest one in medicine
was the genome ah now we can cure
everything
well I guess what maybe we can make uh
designer babies too
uh hmm well
maybe that's not so good so that wasn't
we're still dealing with that struggle
crispr came along
we can modify genetics
and I I'm I'm telling Berkeley the
founder of crispr was from Berkeley and
that's where I did my physics she was
not there at the time but uh uh at any
rate the long and the short of it um
we're still struggling with that
where is it appropriate and not and the
technology is is developing so there's a
variety of forms of of crispr of the
original technology
getting even further down to the
molecular level
you may or may not be aware that there
was a famous problem in biology called
the protein folding problem
now proteins are made of amino acids
sort of lined up lined up just like in
our DNA string of molecules proteins are
a string of amino acids
and they're lined up like beads on a
necklace
but they they the proteins that don't
stay like a string they fold into a
particular configuration
and that's how they do their activity in
in that configuration
and a huge amounts of effort have been
exerted to figure out that configuration
because now you can make a pharmacist
can come along and design a medication
to fit that configuration
or a vaccine to fit the configuration of
a virus
so the configuration is really crucial
in proteins it was called the protein
folding problem
and we used X-ray crystallography
to decide what that configuration looked
like
well that is trust me
is extremely difficult
and extremely time consuming
well just recently within the last year
or two there was a contest
and it was um Google through a program
called Alpha fold
two
designed a program
and there was a contest an international
contest
who could take the string of beads of
amino acids and predict
what the protein looks like
and they got better and better and and
Google with Alpha fold one the first
round and the second round
and most recently
they have predicted
with 100 basically one hundred percent
accuracy
the configuration of any protein
well now the X-ray crystallographers are
out of work
so to speak
but what does that mean
knowing the configuration of proteins
because proteins are what make
uh the fine-tuning of what makes every
cell in our body work
they're enzymes and we know Pro enzymes
are proteins
and a lot of our medications very subtly
change what an enzyme looks like to make
it work or not work
if you know the structure of it
okay just by plugging it into a computer
the pharmacist then say whoa this is a
piece of cake man can I do this with
great ease
where the rubber meets the road is with
that kind of potential
you can now take blood from anybody you
want
look at their proteins
and decide what the configuration what
what the deficiency is
and potentially how to correct it
but as you might guess
a lot of I'm for those who can't see I'm
I guess we don't have video but I'm
rubbing my fingers like money you hand
surgeon
money money money it takes a lot of
money
um and that's where we were trying to
meet you know our technology is getting
tremendously expensive
but it's tremendously personalized and
for the term used in this committee
precise
is truly Precision medicine because it
is indeed
looking at you as an individual
personalized and that's one of the terms
that came out
in the late 70s instead of precision
medicine was personalized medicine and
was a term that's used and that's gone
by the boards at this juncture
um
but that's the track we're taking from
the my great great grandfather horseback
doctor to now being able to predict
through a computer you know what I may
or may not need
but there comes our role here from my
perspective that indeed what we have to
do is is to try and ferret out
you know what is legitimate science
and what is legitimately applied
contrary to Lone marrow transplants for
breast cancer
we want to be able to Step Beyond the
emotional content
and look at the objective content
and once we've decided on the objective
content then we can make the assessment
of what are the kinds of things that we
need to be doing to make it happen
properly
and that's how I view our charge
and I think I held it under 45 so I beat
that academic standard of 45 minutes
thank you
thank you representative
um are there questions before I ask my
questions
seeing none
representative
uh I have a question that I will ask you
and I will ask all of our other
presenters
the gold standard
for the application of any intervention
is the clinical trial
it's the clinical study
um and that and the clinical study is
designed to determine if an intervention
is effective and What proportion of the
time it is effective
to your knowledge have there been
clinical trials
of preventive of precision medicine
and how does it Shape Up
oh there's
there's been a number of Trials some
with animals and some uh with
individuals
um you may have heard early on uh that
uh some of the the genetic modification
occurred and Hopkins ran into a problem
uh with a young man and I've forgotten
he had a um a muscle disorder and then
details of Escape me but again the side
effects so yes there have been
to be more specific there have been a
number of study in mice being able to
identify
cancer cells specifically prostate
cancer cells and tart and looking at
their surface configuration
designing a specific molecule that will
attach to that surface antigen
and then I have the
active moiety or the active part of that
molecule once it's attached able to
enter the cell
okay so it's all only entering a cancer
cell
and release its medication and kill only
the cancer cells
so those are the kinds of
specific studies that have been done
again those the ones I'm familiar with
are in mice but similar studies are in
progress in another a number of areas I
have not been able to keep up with a
clinical
studies that may have used molecular
Dynamics
um
and hopefully we will be able to hear
some some testimony in that regard
if I may follow that up
and I'm trying to be very cautious in my
question
I don't hear you saying
yes at this point there have been
clinical trials of uh
genotyping and Drug matching
that give us a very focused view of how
effective the approach is compared to
traditional interventions
is that a reasonable statement the
answer is yes and the reason I
um would hesitate is because the
complexity that's involved in terms of
the typical I'll say typical
standard is the the double-blind studies
okay that's the typical okay what we're
talking about here is not mass data okay
and generalized data but we're talking
about specific and therefore the Cadre
of people you're interacting with is
very very small
and we also know from the standpoint of
complexity that in fact these organisms
that were are
diagnoses that were working with are
very very
um
niche in terms of their characteristics
and as with any medication we don't know
there's no way to get a good handle on
some of the molecular dynamics that will
occur
given you know that may be addressed in
other words you may conf find out the
configuration of an enzyme design a
medication
but
find out that the medication that you
design
runs into problems with some other
aspect of the physiology an example I
give is when we had uh penicillin
it first came out
okay it looked good in the petri dish
and the application to humans by God
terrible everybody
killed people
well
turns out it wasn't the penicillin it
was the actual carrier moiety molecules
are made up of two parts one is a part
that holds on to the molecule you want
to use and that carries it into the
biologic system
and it gets released and does its
activity well you got this other part
running around and you may be allergic
to that and that's what happened with
Penicillin so everybody ran into
problems with Penicillin he said oh we
can't use it well they designed another
carrier moiety
and carried it in okay
and that brings us to how medications
are reviewed medications are reviewed
from a
a a standard first of all it has to be
pharmacist comes up with a chemical
number one it has passed mustard that in
fact they can make it chemically pure
they can reproduce in other way they can
make the chemical correctly
but not a lot of that sounds kind of
silly but when you have a chemical
reaction there are certain side
reactions that go on and contaminate
can contaminate your batch it's got to
be pure
so that's number one
number two it has to be biologically
active well in other words
um it's got to be something that the the
system that you're introducing it to
doesn't have like the moiety with
Penicillin react to so you may get the
chemical
and yes you can make it pure
but the biologic system the human being
says I don't like it
so that's the second standard that you
have to have with the FDA when you look
for approval the third it has to be
physiologically active
okay in other words I can make it pure
secondly I can make it biologically
compatible
okay it gets in fine but then does
nothing
okay it doesn't do what it's supposed to
do
so yes you can design it to fit that
enzyme
by mathematics
but by the time you go through and make
it pure
and compatible with the biologic system
it may not be physiologically active
so they're those are the three steps
when you have to consider so we can't
consider just making
intellectually making the molecule
and applying it in a Precision fashion
our biologic systems sometimes are more
complex than that and don't allow that
to work and that's where the clinical
trials come in
uh and so we're sort of back to where we
started from we can't use a standard
approach because we can't use
double-blind studies it's just nuts that
is the gold standard so what we're
trying to do is to proceed in a
scientific manner
along lines that that don't allow us to
use what has been the gold standard the
double-plane study because I mean there
may not be enough people with a
particular diagnosis to make it you
can't make a double blind
just not going to happen so those are
the some of the I'm sort of wandering
into separate areas but hopefully this
has been instructional
so people understand the complexity not
physiologically complex but also the
other complexities that that we're
facing when we make these decisions
I would agree with what you're saying Dr
Woods um representative Woods one of the
challenges that
we have on the horizon is that when we
had
chemicals drugs
they came from a chemical
it was easier to make it pure to achieve
the goals you're talking about also we
had clinical trials because we had an N
of many
when you get to personalized medication
down to precise medication you're down
to an N of a few
so to your point it's gonna be very
difficult to use that standard having a
clinical trial which you're trying to
carry out something across a population
of hundreds of thousands versus
population of maybe 100
and that's going to be a real challenge
I think for all of us is how do we
identify the process
in order to achieve that goal
and it's going to be thinking
differently it's going to be pulling a
lot of folks together and trying to talk
about it what I concern myself with
and this is back to building awareness
as well as access
and this is a quadri we talked about
this earlier with the attorney Williams
and also with permisses Clifford
is how as a society we're going to pay
for this
a good example that is when we had
hepatitis C
and they came out with a true cure of
hepatitis A
phenomenal
but how do you price it because if all
of a sudden you're the person in the
business model and you're trying to
have a revenue stream coming in over
multiple years
and all of a sudden you lose those
multiple years of Revenue
how do you price the product in the
market
for society to benefit from it
so it goes back into I think what you
talked about before is
how do we pay for it in a lot of ways it
may end up costing us less money
in the long run but in the short run it
hurts
it's the same thing with sickle cell
anemia you're having now with gene
therapy you can fix it
but how do you
price it in the market in such a way
that you can recover all the r d because
you only have one
shot at it
versus somebody's you're going to have
therapy for multiple years
if I might
um again this what I call I get to what
I have referred to in committee is with
global dollars
um if you can solve problem a you will
have a return on an investment of
X
if you incorporate
the use of a to begin with is what
you're what you're referring to
the difficulty the the people that
benefit may not be the people okay that
you first note and example I give from
Orthopedics
is
arthroscopic surgery we all know
arthroscopic surgery and probably
everybody in the rooms had arthroscopic
surgery
at any rate if you had a had a knee
problem in the late 60s
when I started my training if you needed
your meniscus out you
first of all you didn't do much with it
well you go to physical therapy and you
do this and you work along with it and
blah blah blah if you really had to take
it out
um okay but if you're admitted to the
hospital maybe for two or three days a
big incision uh with the risks of
infection as well higher than
arthroscopy
um and the long and short of it uh by
that time the arthritis has probably
already set in you may miss the last
five to ten years of your work life
and more likely to have a total joint
Etc
arthroscopy you can prevent that in a
number of instances
and prevent the arthritis and so the
workforce you you gain that so Society
gets back
okay no hospitalization
back to work not in six weeks but in
sometimes just a day or two
um may not need the total joint another
added cost through the Medicare program
uh and maybe won't need the facility
needs for a rehab
as well so there's a huge benefit
that is not realized other than up front
where you pay for the arthroscopy
um and as a consequence when we look at
this
um we we there's no way to figure in
there's no way for our health system to
look at Global dollars
because we have fragmented Health Care
system so part of it focuses back on our
Healthcare System in general
but harking back to this how are we
going to pay for this because there is
benefit and I asked the the rep
open Forum here uh in town he came and
asked him how could how do you justify
six hundred thousand dollars for the hep
C vaccination he says well you do
realize that we're providing a benefit
to society
I mean if you cure this he's not missing
work okay that's benefit to the employer
multiple multiple multiple
hospitalization in the course of hep C
hospitals are benefiting tremendously
um you may not need a liver transplant
down the road I mean this is huge I mean
we're we are saving millions and
millions of dollars
so therefore we feel we can justify
you know as contributing to saving all
this money that the six hundred thousand
dollars is well Justified
however I'll just offer my counter to
that
I said well I don't I'm not too sure I
understand your reasoning just because
you can doesn't mean you do it or can
I said I'm a hand surgeon and I've
reattached maybe a hundred hands and
arms not here in rush in Concord but at
Rochester
and um
uh one particular lady a severed hand
dominant hand
workers comp
um
back to work in three months not the
same job but also taking care of her
invalent husband at that point
so I said again this was in 70
6 I think something like that
um for the team that took 19 to 20 hours
to do that we got three thousand dollars
I said workers comp
okay had she lost her dominant hand pays
a lump sum to pay it depending upon what
part is missing and for a dominant hand
to be missing permanently in her age
group she was only 40 something years
old
I said let's just pick a number let's
say that she would have gotten a lump
sum through workers comp of a million
bucks
compensation
so
I saved uh or a team not me it was about
a 23 hour operation
so I saved the system maybe a million
dollars there
so
maybe 250 000 would have been reasonable
fee
he said well here's my card why don't we
talk about this next time you're in New
York
was his response
but this is we have to think about
global dollars we have to think about
how we and I'm talking about globally
weak how do we as the pharmacy industry
look at our profit margin and what is
our contribution
to society and surgeons the same way I
mean I'm talking about I mean they have
to say you know um
you know
uh anyway
I would encourage this task force that
we our legislation that creates the task
force to include in broaden
the composition of the task force to
include those from the insurance
industry possibly those from the
business community that are either in
Pharmaceuticals or in this space because
I think we need to really understand
from their point of view the economics
of it if we're trying to ensure that we
build awareness and build access a lot
of the access is going to be predicated
upon the ability
for somebody to pay the bill
and when you get down to that point in
time stick when you get down to
personalized medicine or Precision
medicine and you have a cohort of many
many covered lives in a plan
but you only have one or two individuals
within 100 000 that are going to benefit
for something that cost six hundred
thousand dollars it's going to hit the
premium so therefore how do we as a
society how does the business Community
how do we work with them collectively to
ensure that all the work we're doing
actually becomes achievable for the
patient as well
uh
representative gay
foreign
way to address you thank you Mr chairman
I guess it would be Mr chairman okay all
right thank you Mr chairman
um and this is not exactly a question
but it's an observation uh recently in
the last two years with all the pandemic
and the treatments and practices
this idea of changing our view on what
constitutes the equivalence to a
clinical trial
became a very apparent because if
somebody is at risk of dying
are you really going to do a clinical
trial and deny some people a treatment
so I'm glad this issue is coming up
because it's
it's a new world you know ethically how
do you do a clinical trial I'd help them
think ethically you can when somebody's
life is on the line and you have a
treatment
that you think works
um so that's one little thing that needs
to be ironed out here
when you determine whether the treatment
is effective
um
so I just wanted to point out that
that's one little one little thing that
we're discussing here
uh everything you've said right now
makes really good sense and we certainly
if we're going to do a thorough job we
do need to put the the money people here
to say how how it affects everybody else
thank you representative representative
candid
thank you Mr chair
with the discussion we're talking about
money associated with something that but
really bottom line that's what it comes
down to and
um and it comes to the question of
what's the potential for industry
funding to research this have having
a member of the pharmaceutical Community
as a part of my family and I part of an
r d organization I know that they do
work on products that never come to
Market and coming from the computer
industry I knew that we spent millions
of dollars on products that never came
to Market and and part of part of the
question here is where we may have
individuals that have a need that's
currently solved by a very expensive
process and products is
should we be challenging the industry
and and their money
to find ways to
address this issue
maybe in ways that we haven't even
thought of currently instead of putting
the the
financial burden on the patient or even
on their insurance is to go back to the
industry and say can you put money into
investigating this to determine are
there more than one or more than a
hundred people
considering that we may be looking at
our Market here in the U.S and maybe
Europe but it could be much broader than
that
and and for us to in to to put get
someone from industry to talk with us on
this topic but uh it's also
the realization is that currently
people are working on products that may
never come to Market and they are
spending millions of dollars on these
products
um with the goal of
maybe bringing it to a clinical trial
that would in fact prove that the
product doesn't address the need anyways
so uh that that's my question I have
another question for this committee is
is do we have specific dates in which we
need to come up with what we're
discussing here and
uh if I can respond to that
um
I foolishly
promised chairman Pearson that we would
wrap this up by the end of November
I suspect I will live to regret that
statement
Mr chairman I I think that the goal is
to develop a
LSR
that we can introduce in November we may
be able to hit that goal and then at
that point in time it would transition
from this body to another body to become
the actual task force I think this is
really kind of setting the stage to
create the LSR
and then from there to hopefully get it
into place
or maybe if you're thinking about having
it become a permanent
subcommittee of the oversight committee
which we could do without creating an
LSR that would be the decision of the
chair thank you
um
representative gay
thank you Mr chairman
um recently sometime in the last 10
years I read about the junk bond King
who and I can't remember his name but he
was in prison because he had ripped off
people
he came up yeah when you think of it say
it
um he discovered because he insisted on
getting an uh physical after he got out
of prison he insisted on a um
what is the test for prostate cancer
a PSA yeah and the doctor kept saying
You're So Young You couldn't possibly
have it well he insisted and he had like
stage three
without any symptoms
um and so he became he used some of his
uh creative
thought to go to conferences where he
wasn't a medical person you were
supposed to be a certified doctor to be
there but he kind of faked it and used
his mother's maiden name and went and
got the attention of everybody there by
his in absolutely heartfelt uh appeal to
do research
and to share that research he found
money got more people to contribute it
to pay to pay for research but it also
meant that if you accepted the money you
gave a report every year you didn't wait
until you had a marketable product and
that way and it was successful and that
way they piggybacked on each other so
you went and contributed what you had
learned in that year
even though you really was hoping you
could keep developing it and end up
making a lot of money this way the
research was much faster because when
everybody contributed what they had
learned everybody else could use that
in their own research and so they had
much more success so I'm just throwing
this out there because I hope that
anything that we promote
also promotes
I'm sure there's a two-bit word for it
but it means that you're contributing
and you're Building Together
much faster than everybody going off on
their own
I'd like to make a brief less than 45
minutes closing statement and I'd like
to adjourn this meeting because I'm
freezing
um it's it and I want to go outside to
warm up
um
I I would like to say
I spent
the majority of my career teaching
epidemiology
at undergraduate and graduate levels
um I if I recall I'm not positive this
but I believe that Ms minnehan who is
not present in the room so I can say
this uh suffered through my epidemiology
class
um
in in my teaching
what I taught was that the succession of
studies
case control studies cohort studies were
always
good at generating hypotheses but the
clinical trial was the gold standard
and only when you had succeeded at the
clinical trial
did you let us say go to the bank on an
intervention
and as I listened to today's testimony
it begins to occur to me that the
clinical trial is no longer the adequate
gold standard there are other
imperatives
in tracking the success of interventions
that we have to use
and
our world of uh epidemiologic
investigation has changed I am now an
Antiquity
and would no longer be effective at
teaching that class
the other thing that I have heard today
which I think is terribly important
two parts
one is that we are looking at outcomes
for individual patients and outcomes for
our population as a whole and they may
be very different
the final comment that I want to make is
a piggyback to representative Woods
observation that in many cases we're
looking at wider impact broader impacts
than we see in an individual case
uh for example we now have uh trials
going on on a medication to slow the
advance of Alzheimer's disease
one has to realize that the Alzheimer's
patient represents a cost not just to
the patient but to the family as well
to the entire household in some cases to
the community if a person needs daycare
it needs to be under memory care unit
and so forth and in that case it is
possible that the slope
the slowing of the advance of the
disease actually costs more than simply
letting it run its course
I will tell one anecdote it comes
courtesy of uh Dr Jack Fox who was at
the time that I knew him the chairman of
Neurology at Rush Medical Center in
Chicago he's currently the dean of Rush
medical school and he talked about
a family coming to him and saying well
you know Mom has Alzheimer's and we want
your advice as to whether to provide her
immunization against influenza
and his recommendation was
I would not recommend it
and his reasoning was that Mom was an
extreme burden on the Family
a financial burden
uh members of the family could not go
out to work
um this was a disease for which we did
not have an effective treatment
it was ultimately a terminal disease
and the impact the financial and
emotional impact on the Family
would be diminished
were mom to develop influenza and
pneumonia
and perish
it's a chilling chilling thought
and yet it is the sort of thought that
we have to process in this committee
so
um with that I would like to thank you
all profoundly for your patience under
duress in this cold cold room thank you
for and I'm I must tell you that as
difficult as it has been in terms of our
temperature environment this has been
extremely extremely rewarding in terms
of opening up our awareness of the
issues in Precision medicine and I thank
you all for putting up with the duress
Mr chair yes I might uh did you want to
talk about meeting times
um
a
this is going to get interesting
if the if this is going to happen every
Monday morning
I'm not meeting on Mondays
and I why don't we representative gay
thank you I will get a hold of Christina
Dyer who's our staffer and suggest to
her that we change our meeting days to a
day when the heat's on
um that uh we can't let this happen
again I've got a meeting this afternoon
that's you know very important meeting
and
just can't put up with this I can't
imagine that any state in the Union
operates this way so
I'll I'll see if I can change that okay
thank you very much everyone
thank you
this opens the hearing
and I do not know where the chair Pro
tem is but I'm the chair of oversight so
I'm going to open the meeting and that's
a good way of making sure he'll show up
in about 20 seconds
the hope that I have as chairman of
oversight and that I have for this
subcommittee is that we find a way to be
appropriately
transparent when it comes to Serious
medical mistakes
uh for the record my wife is a family
practice physician
and we know that sometimes when a claim
is made against a physician this
frivolous
some insurance companies say it's
cheaper to settle the claim by giving
them a small amount of money to make
them go away than it is to fight it we
would win but it's more expensive so
we'll settle
but then there's a black mark that goes
against that physician who knows if
there's just something listed as a
malpractice situation whether it was
to the level of criminal negligence or
to the level of frivolity or what
My Hope Is that eventually we are able
to have a mechanism of reporting
where
Physicians and hospitals that are either
totally innocent or
the mistakes that were made are the kind
of mistakes that are made because we're
human
but on the other hand protect the public
by making sure that those whose level of
performance is horrid where colleagues
complain those people are known for what
they did wrong whether it goes to a
court trial or not that was the hope
that I had when I put this subcommittee
together and I'm hoping over the next
three weeks of meetings that is what we
will find a vehicle to do
uh with that I would like to call on
other members of the committee if you
would
um
share with us what you would like to see
happen representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman
um
I'm a draftee so I didn't come with any
preconceived notions I want very much to
listen to what folks who have been
involved in the process have to say and
then I'll figure out where I want to go
with it after that but I thank you okay
I was hoping for more because I'm in the
same situation at the present I'm trying
to put together a schedule in my mind as
we speak anyone else on the committee
who might like to speak representative
Jess Edwards uh thank you Mr chair I I
I'd say that um
my objective here not having a
background in how our Board of Medicine
reports uh is to learn a lot and if
we're going to come up with any uh
legislation I'd like us to make sure
that we follow a disciplined Ready Aim
Fire
perspective where uh before we start to
go down the road of any changes in
legislation that we really make sure
that we understand do we have a problem
or not if there's if there's not really
a problem Beyond perception we ought to
handle that differently than if there is
a real issue that you know maybe Maine
or Vermont or Massachusetts or somebody
does it better than us and it's an issue
of procedures and policies but but I
don't I don't I don't even want to start
down that unless
we can conclude that there's an actual
problem that we're attempting to solve
and then these are problem-solving
skills after that but anyone on the
committee wish to speak to what the
problem might be
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman my name is Jim
Murphy
I have practice in medicine for 40 years
and I would agree with you with the
understanding that we would like to
understand first the process going
forward the um the statutes that we
currently have in our state and if
there's any way to improve upon him
um that that's what we would be
ultimately charged to do having said
that I think that as has been mentioned
I think we are in a
a discovery phase right now trying to
understand exactly where we are uh in
the state but also relative to other
states and how the process works there
as well
um
so I'm very interested in hearing from
those that will be presenting to us and
trying to come up with a um a logical
um solution if there is a need for a
solution
because the problem to me is that we
simply at this point in time we simply
don't understand and we need to get a
little better understanding of the
current process but the impetus for this
was a series of articles in the Boston
Globe which
highlighted a significant difference in
how the Massachusetts Board of Medicine
reporting and how the New Hampshire
Board of Medicine reported on the same
individual and the Massachusetts board
reports 20 of what I believe wore 21
I'll just use the word malpractice
situations and try to make that as uh
non
judgmental as possible but there were 20
instances reported on an individual from
what I read I could not tell whether
this was frivolous criminal anything in
between it was just events
at the same time the New Hampshire board
reported zero
and that isn't to say one is better than
the other it's just where we're starting
is what and why
um
anyone else on the committee
attorney
John Pearson thank you very much
um we are here I'm sure for the
introduction to the audience my name is
John Williams I'm the director of
legislative affairs and it is an honor
to be able to serve on the subcommittee
and be appointed and we're here as a
resource committee along with my
colleague attorney Douglas osterhout
from the office of professional
licensure and certification I certainly
would turn it over to Doug for
introductions and uh his thoughts and
Impressions on our participation with
this very important task
chair recognizes Council also house
thank you very much
um I may not be 100 I am
recovery stages right now I'm sorry I
cannot hear you uh I might not be 100
today I'm on the recovery stages okay
and
um but as attorney William said I am
Douglas elster how I am general counsel
for the office of professional licensure
and certification and I am here as a
resource to maybe help you through the
process and questions you might have
is attorney Bond here from the ag office
okay
the chair would like to call on oplc and
whichever one of you would like to speak
to that uh
one of the most important things of your
testifying is turn the mic on
well done
please let us know
thank you representative
um for the record my name is Lindsay
Courtney I'm the executive director of
The Office of professional life
insurance certification which is the
state agency charged with providing
administrative support to the majority
of our licensing boards including the
Board of Medicine
I don't have any prepared remarks I'm
happy to answer any questions you may
have regarding the current process in
terms of what we post why we post it
when we post it
um but if there's something specifically
that you would like me to cover
please let me know
cheer would like to know what are the
rules for
the Board of Medicine in terms of
disclosure because
representative Edwards with the staff
here has done a great job in finding out
what every state is supposed to do what
are the rules and regulations for New
Hampshire for posting on malpractice
so generally the rules specific to the
Board of Medicine are consistent with
the statutory requirements for all other
licensing boards and the statutes can
obviously be found in the various board
practice acts but
um essentially we only publicly disclose
information if there has been a
disciplinary action a notice of hearing
has been issued
after a notice of hearing is issued
information that is generated through
our office and the board is considered
public information and that is what is
posted to our website as well as the
licensing portal
we do receive reports of lawsuits that
comes directly from the court and that
is actually unique to the Board of
Medicine we do not receive lawsuits from
the court involving other professions
when we receive those lawsuits that is
considered a complaint we treat them as
such meaning that the
um it goes through the investigative
process and if there ends up being
disciplinary action taken at that time
that's when it is posted
let me clarify that you get information
from the courts about lawsuits that is
not posted correct only if anything from
the lawsuits becomes disciplinary action
correct and who disciplines
the board the Board of Medicine correct
okay so then theoretically
um there could be all kinds of lawsuits
settled out of court that you don't hear
about and because you're not working on
different rules you're working on these
rules
um we don't
we don't hear about them
well we do also query the National
Practitioner Data Bank we are required
to do so under federal law
and that uh that tells us whether or not
there's been a malpractice payout
um basically an insurance claim and so
we treat those as complaints as well
um when we either query or we receive
notice from the National Practitioner
Data Bank of a payout
um it is treated as a complaint it's
investigated pursuant to the
investigative procedures and if it
results in a notice of hearing it gets
reported as such
representative Weber
I think you just answered my question
but I want to be sure I have it correct
so
a simple payout does never arises to the
level of something that gets noticed but
it may trigger
a hearing on whether actual disciplinary
action is needed is have I got that the
right way around yes and the theory
behind that is that the justification
for taking action in a licensure case is
different than a malpractice case and
malpractice is generally concerned with
negligence the boards typically from an
ethical standpoint only act if it's
gross negligence or there are specific
violations of their ethical code or
their practice act and so just because
there has been a payout which
may or may not mean that there was
negligence that does not necessarily
translate to
justification for abort disciplinary
decision so there needs to be that
case-by-case analysis and that is that
is done by the board okay thank you
given that
um could you speak to the fact that
there were none of the 20 items that
were reported in Massachusetts were
reported in New Hampshire
what should one infer from that I I
can't speak to any
um investigative information all I can
tell you is that
that absence means that the board did
not take disciplinary
did not have a disciplinary decision
that was reportable
thank you
um
I'll fill the clerk's job if you want to
fill the Chairman's jobs not fair enough
oh well I'm doing both right now
okay bye
yes you may
thank you Mr secretary chair
um
okay so I I I want to come back to the
one example that's been in the media uh
and uh as the chair is reported there
were 20 incidences reported by the
Massachusetts Board of Medicine and and
zero by us and based on the the
algorithm you gave us on how they become
reportable uh by our board uh it seems
to me like
um the assumption
is that even that that we knew about all
of them and that there were no surprises
because we knew about all of them that
there were some preliminary inquiry into
each of them
that based on the preliminary inquiry
there was an active decision to not do a
full investigation or if there had been
a full investigation we concluded that
there was no gross negligence or no
violation of ethical
standards and therefore not reportable
now the reason I I broke it down so
specifically is because I'm just trying
to um in the management world we call it
an audit you know just walk through did
we comply with our own procedures in a
given case and so this is a bit of a
management audit question for you
certainly and it's a valid question I
think one of the issues that I think has
been raised regarding transparency is I
cannot reveal any information regarding
the investigative process specific to
the cases that were mentioned in the
Boston Globe because it is considered
confidential and there were no public
decisions uh rendered and so when we
talk about transparency that's something
that the committee may wish to consider
is there a middle point at which
information can be publicly shared
um because without that we're we're not
permitted to disclose the information
even if we would like to
oh
okay so
um
I I can understand that
and I'm just trying to figure out how
the the people of New Hampshire can be
comfortable with that and so uh is it
um possible to ask you to go back and
audit yourself your your own board
procedures go through it in the steps
that I just laid out and I can repeat
them I think but
um and then if you find that there was a
breakdown at some point then you could
undergo actions to self-repair
absolutely we can definitely take that
um back and take those actions
um
what we what we wouldn't be able to do
is report on the findings but we can we
can certainly do that analysis
internally but but what would be
reportable is if you went back through
all those steps and you went oh darn we
missed one and now this one needs to be
publicly reported then we would know
that you're publicly reporting it after
the fact so there would at least be some
awareness of whether or not your
internal management audit revealed you
messed up maybe or somebody
right
yes if you go back and it is in
retrospect should have been publicly
reportable and you will still report it
publicly and that would let us know that
your self-audit came up with something I
can assure you that we have reported
everything that could be reported
that we have done that analysis
you've done it you're okay well that's
big news right there thank you so the
question is
how much should be reported I think that
is I think that is the open question
um and oplc doesn't take a position on
that
obviously there are significant
constraints with what we can report now
um many of our boards if I may take a
process just during an investigation
where they receive a complaint
they do an initial inquiry that
typically includes receiving a response
from the licensee
and they make a decision as to whether
or not the complaint is essentially
facially valid
and warrants a formal investigation if
there is a formal investigation most
boards will issue an order of formal
investigation so that's a middle
um
point in the investigative process and
the boards will outline what needs to be
investigated and what the concerns could
be from an investigative standpoint
um one thing the state could consider is
whether or not those orders of formal
investigation should be made public
because that would protect those initial
complaints that are deemed frivolous
that don't warrant an actual
investigation
but then also put the public on notice
when there is an order of formal
investigation that is something that I
think the state could could consider
we're not taking a position on that
um but that I just wanted the committee
to be aware of the the process in which
an investigation
um
flows follow up
that's that's interesting to me the that
that we could report on when there's a
formal investigation that's been
launched uh I would be reluctant to
release that unless or until rather it
got uh resolved and then we could
simultaneously say that there was an
investigation and the official
conclusion was no no harm no foul or we
we've we're following it up and and that
is because uh of the implication of
being under a formal investigation just
the implication alone you're already
guilty in the mind of many and I I don't
know that that would be fair I I what so
what are your what are your thoughts on
maybe uh holding off on reporting a
formal investigation until the it had
come to a formal conclusion that could
also be reported simultaneously
so again we're not taking the agency
doesn't take a position from a policy
standpoint on what should be reported
but I will say that is the current
process we have now
um it we report when a notice appearing
is issued which basically
admits that there has acknowledges that
there has been an investigation that the
board has decided to proceed with
disciplinary action even if after
hearing the case is dismissed that
notice of hearing is public and it's
posted so that is the current system
that we have now and it's probably you
know
because of some of the concerns that you
raised
you're on a roll okay so I I just
declarified if you if you've done a
formal investigation and you decide that
there's no further review required and
you stop the formal investigation with
no conclusion that the fact that you had
a formal investigation is not reportable
is it do you report that now we don't
report it unless the board's decision is
that they would like to pursue
discipline right but if there is no
correct Pursuit then there's nothing
ever reported on the fact that a formal
investigation was opened
that even the fact that there was a
formal investigation is not reported
nothing is reported good I'm just I'm
not trying to argue I'm just trying to
understand the you know when the
switches get thrown absolutely I have a
question before I do anyone in the
audience who wishes to testify uh we
have these pink cards up here that you
need to fill out and pass along up if
it's in your hand it doesn't exist in my
site so bring them on down or pass them
all down and the
blue sheep representative Solway is for
what
those visiting the hearings to register
their name affiliation and whether they
support or do not support
legislation but no legislation
with that uh yes yes uh representative
Murphy
thank you um I just wanted to clarify
um
and you were you said you were required
by federal law to uh query the national
provider Data Bank practitioner databank
is that correct that's correct that's
not a state statute no I believe it's a
federal law obviously there's enabling
statute but it's it's detailed in some
federal regulations
the article I read referenced the fact
that as a result of the healthcare
quality improvement Act of 86 hospitals
are required to
query that data bank but you know states
are not State and medical boards are not
required to do so and they they
suggested that simply that a lot of
states don't query it so you say we are
one that does query it we are and there
are I think there are three regs at
issue I apologize they don't have them
memorized that touch upon when you're
required to query when you're not
required to query the board of dental
examiners and the Board of Medicine are
required to query and we do query for
those two boards
um and then obviously there's a
reporting requirement as well
my other question relates to the fact
that it seems like there may be and you
would know better than I you know as
part of the
um Medical Board and also the um uh
credentialing or you know privileging
and you know licensing board
where do we where do you think we stand
relative to other states with regard to
regulatory oversight of the process of
Licensing you know providers meaning we
feel it lacks do we have very few
regulations controlling the licensing of
providers or are we very restrictive in
many ways where do we fall in that
spectrum is my I'm trying to understand
where we are
so I think that would depend on the
profession
um we're in medicine then well
I'm not really in a position to comment
on that because my job is to provide
administrative support I would defer to
Dr Baker who I know is here
um who can comment on that um
as I'm not a member of the profession so
I from a licensing standpoint I can't
um comment
so just so just to be clear your role
the
your your arm of it is basically an
administrative support for all the
multiple boards
and it's the board of medicine's
responsibility to issue the license and
then recertify a license going forward
every two years which we always did is
that correct
correct although I will say that the
Board of Medicine like most boards has
delegated
certain tasks to the agency such as
renewals issuing licenses
in between board meetings they'll go on
a consent agenda a lot of Licensing
boards have delegated that to our office
if it is objective criteria but yes my
job is to oversee the administrative
support to all of the licensing boards
which would include posting information
online and working with the Department
of Information Technology to make sure
that we have a portal and interface with
the appropriate
websites in order to make reporting
happen great thank you you're welcome
who decides how
something
is to
to proceed in terms of Investigations is
that something each board decides and
then you as an administrative arm carry
that out
what can you decide
uh no all of the authority to
investigate and to
conduct disciplinary proceedings
generally resides with the licensing
boards the
Board of Medicine is unique because they
have the medical review subcommittee
which is a creature of Statute there are
Physicians and public members who are
appointed by governor and Council to
serve on that and they are essentially
an investigative arm of the Board of
Medicine to assist the Board of Medicine
with the investigative process we
provide administrative support
um but ultimately the decisions reside
with the boards
thank you any further questions yeah
representative Edwards okay I'm going to
shift on you a little bit uh since you
mentioned websites and
um the person who who came up with all
this documentation works for legislative
services and he did a great job Mr
Richard Latham and so I want to thank
him for that but I I want to just share
with you his observation as he was going
to get this information from various
States websites he loved the main
website he said it was beautifully laid
out it was easy to navigate and and he
thought Massachusetts and Vermont also
had very nice websites
I I I I I I I I think we may have come
in forth in that beauty contest though
do you do you have any insight about
what we're doing to upgrade our our web
um
what the public portion of our web yes
um as you know doit
essentially controls that part of the
process oplc was one of the first
agencies when the state received
um some additional Federal funding to
upgrade its website um
the issue that I see that is of most
significance to the agency is the
licensing portal
um it's extremely outdated I want to say
it's about 15 years old the contract is
slated to expire very shortly
um it's uh it breaks all the time I
can't run reports until after my staff
leave because it will crash the system
to make any changes in the system
requires that I reach out to a part-time
contractor for the Department of
Information Technology who only works a
couple days a week
it's is a broken process
we
um we have identity we identified this
as an issue years ago
um when I first came on board
um we are working actively with the doit
to procure a new solution
um the state did just receive a 3.4
million dollars in arpa funding for this
uh purpose
um that will hopefully allow us to
obtain a portal that is a little bit
um
similar to Maine and others that are
that are just better capable of
providing access to information but I'll
tell you that
the reason for the delay is because the
agency can't control its own destiny
with respect to I.T and I fully
appreciate why we need an Enterprise
solution for the state but you know that
we have had funding we have the ability
to fund
um technology we are self-funded agency
and it has it has added significant time
trying to
um work with agency partners
um
basically because you have to convince
them of the priorities so that's where
we stand with regards to the licensing
portal follow up sure so I I want to
acknowledge that you just committed a
grand Act of Candor and I really
appreciate your your transparency given
that is our theme I'm there would be
people that would want to tap dance
around the issue and I really appreciate
that you are very clear thank you
thank you representative would you say a
word or two about the parallel process
that's underway and that is Senator
Carson's chairing of a committee out of
Senate Bill 330 which I believe has to
do with oplc and various of the bureaus
uh compare contrast to us
yeah so the the objective really of that
committee which came about a couple
different pieces of legislation
um That Was Then combined and Senate
Bill 230. yes no 3 30. you're correct
representative
was really just to take a look at how
oplc is functioning as it relates to the
boards
um my perspective is that oplc was
created in
2015. there was probably not a lot of
consensus
um a lot of the boards didn't want to
participate in that initially we do have
very good working relationships with the
majority of boards now but it still
remains clear what the oplc is supposed
to do versus what the boards are
supposed to do as it relates to
Authority fees is a primary example of
that so this committee was really
supposed to help us assess where the
authorities should lie and provide a
clear directive to all of the agencies
um moving forward
thank you very much I I'm it's important
that at least some of us know that
because this is actively working and I'm
hoping
um we are hoping that conclusions we
make will be shuffled over to them as
our little word in thank you absolutely
anyone else for Miss Courtney
saying none thank you so much thank you
all for your time
sure would like to call Dr David Conway
to come up he's provided written
testimony which I've scanned that looks
very good he's an MD he's f-a-c-o-g
fellow of the American College of
gynecology
Obstetrics and Gynecology got it
and then you hit the button to make it
red
ah thank you
okay
um I don't want to read through the
entire sheet here could I ask you to be
a little closer to the mic please
thank you
swallow it okay I didn't want to read
through the entire statement I described
some of my background when I was in
practice I'm now retired I think what's
important for the discussion today is
um I'm speaking for myself I'm not
speaking for the board I was a member of
the mrsc the medical review subcommittee
for six years the last two of which I
was chairman I was a member of the Board
of Medicine for six years the last year
or so I was president of the board and I
have since resigned from the board and
am now the physician investigator for
the board so I can speak to the
investigative process in a fair amount
of detail
I'm seeing you're next to the last
paragraph is one that really is most
germane to our purpose here
yes
are there copies of the testimony
available
or is that just something that was
handed in this morning I'm sorry I
printed two copies that's fine I just
wondered if they were if they're not
will no
well we will get more copies for
everyone
um doctor if you could send an email
copy to me I can distribute it to
everyone okay and you are well I'll give
you a card okay so yes if you would
speak to the next to the last Powers
okay
um
so that when information comes to the
board thank you uh whether it be a
Consumer complaint uh from
um a member of the public whether it's a
complaint from another licensee about a
licensee
whether it's the results of a lawsuit
any kind of law enforcement involvement
then an investigation has started
and uh
it can start with an initial review by
the investigator there are investigators
in the oplc as well as myself who look
at it and if there is no merit to it
it's no further action
um if an investigation is indicated by
that initial review and that initial
review can sometimes look at whether
a licensees practice is a threat to the
public in which case a license can be
suspended for 10 days pending a hearing
um and pending the results of an
investigation that happens occasionally
but not often
once an investigation has started a
response is obtained from The Physician
or like a physician's assistant
as well as medical records and reviewed
by the investigator and if it looks as
if it needs to be further reviewed by
their medical review subcommittee that
information is forwarded to the
committee to do an investigation
results of the investigation can be one
of several it can be found to be
unfounded that it really does not fall
under the statute that there is no
further action
that there's concern there are letters
of concern that can be written where the
statute has not been violated but that
there is concern about the physician's
practice or that the statute has been
violated and the board has chosen
um not to discipline and then finally
there's the decision for recommendation
of discipline and that's coming from the
medical review subcommittee that
recommendation and that review
is then sent to the board to see if the
board agrees with that recommendation
and it's up to the board itself to then
decide the action
nothing becomes public unless it is a
decision for discipline
that if there's a decision for
discipline then it comes down to either
their their being a settlement between
the board and the licensee or that
there's a hearing and both of those
become public and are listed on the
website
thank you Dr Conway I I I got a couple
of questions at the Strategic level I
want to make sure of the context and
then I want to go down into the weeds
with you to get your opinion on
something
uh
for context
um I well I I was I was a
healthcare administrator for 45 years
and so I was I'm just generally aware I
think that the highest malpractice
premiums are are found in OB GYN uh or
or very it's very high up is that right
it's in probably the top three and and
is it the is it the case that the high
insurance premiums May limit the number
of people that will
um serve in that area that they would
seek something that isn't quite as uh
risky
or or we have no shortage of Physicians
because of the malpractice premium
I'm sure there's a shortage I can't
speak to that
um I chose a very long time ago to go
into obstetrics and
um
that
I've said when I was working in the
residency over Concord Hospital I would
say to the residents that if you want a
convenient practice if you don't want to
take risk then you should go to
Hannaford and check out groceries okay
so so now I'm about to go into the weeds
if I may
um I I'm I'm exploring the thought
um and it's a it's an ill-form thought
at this point but I want to explore it
with you of whether or not
we should uh after an investigation has
been open and there's a conclusion I I
guess I didn't realize that there were
so many alternative conclusions that
could be reached
um
would would you think it would be a good
idea for any of these scenarios and that
you can uh come to a conclusion but
there's no disciplinary action that's uh
determined that we should report that
there was an investigation and this is
exactly what the status of that
investigation was you mentioned it could
be unfounded no further action taken
statute not violated but the board is
concerned and then you have two or three
other
possibility possible outcomes in your
mind
would it be wise or foolhardy to report
the precise conclusion of the
investigation using
terms such of those six or seven
conditions I think it would be
unfortunate if you did that
and why is that sir that
just because there is a complaint
just because there's a lawsuit does not
mean those Bad Medicine period
but but wouldn't that necessarily show
up in the outcome of the investigation
wouldn't one of these Alternatives be
selected if the board thought that it
was the the for The Meta the clinical
Behavior was acceptable it's just a
complaint I mean why why wouldn't that
be validating for a physician who had
had their work reviewed and had the
board come out basically with a stamp of
approval saying there was a complaint
but we didn't see anything wrong why
wouldn't that be good
I don't think it's fair to the physician
and I will tell you why
I was investigated by the New Hampshire
board several years ago uh probably
about 15 or 20 years ago where I was
pulled in at the very last minute
literally the very last minute for a
delivery by one of the family physicians
that I was covering I was another
partner and I were
initially there were just two of us
hired back in 2001 to cover the
residency as far as women who might need
a cesarean section complications in
pregnancy and so I was asked by this one
provider if I just kind of sit around in
labor and delivery in case they needed
some help
and the help they needed was for a
shoulder dystocia and if you're not sure
what a shoulder dystocia is it's where
the head sort of comes out
and then the shoulder gets stuck behind
pubic bone
and it's terrifying to anyone who's been
involved in that situation
and it took
five or six minutes to really deliver
that child
and the child was neurologically injured
and there are certain
Maneuvers that a provider has to go
through to
actually deliver the child
the most dramatic
is where you try and push the head up
inside
and those results are almost uniformly
terrible
there are other results or other
Maneuvers that you can do to try and
deliver the shoulder that I used
repeatedly and was Abe finally able to
deliver that child
and that's as good as it gets
that you do whatever it is possible to
do and if you have a bad result
sometimes there's no avoiding a bad
result
I can mention that I practiced for about
eight years in Solo practice in
Northwestern Pennsylvania in a rural
area where the nearest tertiary Center
was about two and a half hours away
and having someone come in there were
two instances of twins one at 24 weeks
who came in and both Twins were in
breach position
and she the woman was fully diluted
she was not going to get put into an
ambulance and sent two and a half hours
on the road where she'd likely deliver
on route
it was going to be 45 minutes
flight time to get a helicopter in and
then another 45 minutes to get her to
Pennsylvania to Pittsburgh
and we did the best we could I delivered
two living children one of whom survived
I don't know the results of that
I had another patient arrive at 26 weeks
who was also fully dilated and bleeding
to death
that she had a placenta previa
and we
were able to save her life and also the
baby was delivered alive but
subsequently succumbed
and you do what you can
all right so I I sincerely appreciate
everything you've done that helped our
society with our health care needs I I I
I assume that the point of having a
board of medicine filled with peers with
physician peers is so that they can look
into the clinical facts of the situation
and they can make a informed medical
opinion on whether or not the the the
the the the complaint is unfounded or
not and I I assume based on those two
cases you said that they would come back
with an unfounded status uh even though
there was an investigation if if if as a
physician would it be detrimental to
your career to have knowledge that there
was an investigation and you came out
clean with an unfounded finding I I'm
still just wondering a lot out if if
that's actually good policy to validate
that you've been reviewed and and and
everything's fine
do you is it is it still your position
that even if there's a unfounded status
that the fact that there was an
investigation should not be made public
I think it is unfair yes
representative Weber
thank you
foreign
thank you doctor I was really interested
in your explanation about the different
categories of disposition
and I'm far less interested in the
unfounded issues and I will just state
for anybody who doesn't know me that I'm
an attorney by training although retired
and so I have some experience of the
same kinds of issues of what happens
when somebody complains because they're
annoyed
but there isn't anything founded as to
something you've done wrong
what I'm interested in is the category
that you said
is that one category is when the statute
has been violated but the board has
decided not to discipline
and that seems to me to be a very
different category
than the unfounded or a letter of
concern because those don't arise to a
statutory violation
so I was wondering if you could just
give me generally an idea of what kind
of thing
might be found in the category of
something that
is a violation of Statute but no
discipline is resulting and then give me
your opinion about why that perhaps
should or should not be reported because
that seems to me to be a bright line as
opposed to the squishy stuff okay
should keep medical records reflecting
care
and that they should be legible
sure
and I will tell you that my experience
on the medical view subcommittee I
looked at
a variety of records that were not
legible
and so the report out was that you know
we're not going to discipline you even
though this is a violation of Statute
but boy Shape Up This is the electronic
age
and we can't read what you write
okay
representative Murphy
thank you
my question is how much of the data that
or the various categories that are
resolved with your review of cases is
actually submitted or entered into the
National Practitioner database okay is
it only the untold the bad results or
the ones can you know with a penalty or
all of them the only ones that were
reported to the National Data Bank are
ones that go to discipline whether it
actually comes to a hearing or whether
it comes to a settlement
in reference to your comment about
Hannaford's with the residents at
Concord Hospital that was a little
tongue-in-cheek yeah
my experience has made me yours as well
is that those that were afraid to get
into the fire will drop the OB part of
the OB GYN practice and practice only
GYN less risk involved that sort of
thing potentially
my my question is there are
practitioners that will only take the
easy cases surgically and they have low
risk involved there are others that have
significant Acuity to their practice
High Acuity referral centers by the
nature of it they're going to have a
potential problem on a number of cases
so my question is the ones in the middle
those that don't know their boundaries
those that practice beyond the scope of
their skill set do you believe that in
your experience with the board that
those are the ones that are adequately
vetted out and identified or is there or
is it across the entire Spectrum
it's hard to answer that when you're
talking about vetting who are you
licensing and people that are licensees
that are applying for a license have to
submit a variety of information that
includes malpractice suits
that uh
misdemeanors from before medical school
any number of things that Ms Courtney
described
that the they vetted some of the license
approvals to administrative staff
anything that falls out in that initial
review anyone who's had a malpractice
suit anyone who's had any kind of
Investigation in medical school they've
been on probation in residency who've
been on probation uh
anything that falls out and I'm not
hitting everything but
um anything that falls out immediately
goes to the board for review
and uh and it's up to the board then to
review it themselves and decide if if we
want to license this person do we need
more explanation from them than they've
provided uh period
doctor let me give you a hypothetical
suppose a hypothetical physician is
deemed
by medical colleagues to practice
medicine in such a way that
not just the physician takes the tough
cases thank God somebody does but that
this person has gone beyond that into
for very dangerous place
but nothing is reported about this
hypothetical physician on the website
or a website what should we conclude
I'm not sure exactly what you're asking
that that
the board has to hear something
before they can do any kind of
Investigation so if there are
other licensees who are concerned about
someone's practice if they don't make a
complaint to the Board of Medicine the
Board of Medicine doesn't know about it
I'm not sure if that answers your
question
it's hopeful that maybe
I'm not quite sure how to follow it up
I'm looking for something more
um I I will I want to make one statement
that when the Boston Globe article came
out
it was something that just
um
caused me considerable upset sorry
considerable considerable upset okay
that
um
I'm not sure this this kind of off topic
a little bit but I'm not sure if any of
you have ever
heard of Dr Death
who was a neurosurgeon in Texas who
[Music]
um
really
didn't get reported to the board in
Texas it wasn't no complaints were
raised but who was practicing terrible
medicine
and who wasn't finally brought to he's
now incarcerated but was not brought to
any kind of review until
another neurosurgeon had to take one of
his patients in his absence back to the
operating room
and re-operate and find
really terrible surgery
where Hardware That was supposed to be
inserted in a certain way was not
and it wasn't until he was he brought
from that
um
and he took that to the Attorney
General's office and it was the Attorney
General's office who brought that
physician to trial
and sentencing
so
if we don't hear it as a board we don't
know anything about it we can't act on
it
and which
it comes down to other providers who
will make a complaint uh if that is done
then those cases are reviewed it comes
down to insurers informing the board
that somebody has settled it comes down
to reviewing reports from the National
Data Bank to see okay who's settled
I share your concern
I've spent 12 over 12 years
associated with the Board of Medicine
trying to make sure that
patients get adequate care I spent if
you look at my statement I've spent a
fair amount of time in practice doing
the same thing
so I share your concerns
thank you Doctor any further questions
for Dr Conroy
representative Solway
uh thank you representative Pearson an
apology to those assembled that I was
not here on time I was over in the
Legislative Office Building on time
regrettably apparently the sign
redirecting here must have fallen off it
was not there or visible and there was
no one from the committee there to
inform me that it had been relocated so
it came as a surprise and I'm certainly
glad finally to be here to be with you
Dr Conway uh
oftentimes when there is a claim
it is settled through insurance
there is a settlement
and oftentimes there is an attorney and
uh very commonly there's a
non-disclosure agreement am I correct so
far yes
does the board attend to
does it alter Its Behavior in the light
of is it limited by in any way such
non-disclosure agreements I have no idea
that's a lawyer question
we're going to have to find a lawyer to
address that issue thank you Dr Conway
okay
well thank you very much yes okay okay
so do do we have anyone on our pink
cards who seems to be the subject matter
expert on malpractice insurance premium
setting because I I have a specific
question about that
okay
would at winner Van Der Zander Esquire
be able to answer that question
okay come on up and um it's a two-seater
I think unless there's any further
questions for Dr Conway thank you so
much sir
for the record on midwin of andersanden
I practice law with the firm of
getmanship to steer and Poulin an
insurance defense firm in Manchester and
I have been there for 23 years
I practiced largely in the area of
professional negligence defending
primarily institutions long-term care
facilities Etc I've also represented
nurses Physicians and dentists before
the respective boards in disciplinary
matters
I've also done some plaintiff's work
so I thought it might be helpful to just
quickly encapsulate for you what I think
is troubling you the most and that is
that there seems to be a substantial
period of time between malpractice and
remedy
and notice to the public and that is a
function largely of the statutes that
have been promulgated both federally and
in the state to try and address what has
been perceived as a malpractice crisis
I should also point out that research
has been done by various medical
institutions not the least of which was
John Hopkins University School of
Medicine
that determined that the malpractice
system really doesn't work very well to
address true malpractice
that there are claims that are brought
and this was more true back in the early
years of the malpractice crisis before
the institution of the National
Practitioner Data Bank
that were settled because the Physicians
didn't wish to have the fact of a
malpractice claim
noticed to the public and so as soon as
a claim was threatened if there was even
a perceived bit of Merit to it insurers
paid up to protect their insurance
that don't happen no more
since the National Practitioner Data
Bank was put into practice in I think it
was 1986. it has become a requirement
that every settlement or verdict that is
paid by any insurer and that is entered
into by any practitioner must be filed
with the National Practitioner Data Bank
then hospitals who are looking to hire
Physicians query the National
Practitioner Data Bank to discover
whether there have been claims settled
or verdicts paid on behalf of that
physician
in New Hampshire you have a statutory
requirement that investigations of
Physicians are confidential and as has
been noticed earlier cannot be disclosed
until disciplinary action is complete
um
there is another step in this process
that has not been discussed and I think
it's the one that is troubling the
committee and that is that
peers the Physicians peers his
colleagues are generally the first to
know that someone is not practicing up
to standards and they have an obligation
to report
but they report to their Hospital
credentials committee
and being a hospital credentials
Committee Member not only involves
allowing a physician to become
admitted to have privileges in the
institution
it's also the job of the credentials
committee that they act upon and
investigate complaints of their
colleagues that someone is not
practicing in accordance with the
standards of the institution
so in the case where you have 20 or 21
terrible outcomes
it would have been the very the very
first line of defense for the public
would have and should have been the
hospital credentials committee the
committee meets
brings forward all of the records of all
of the procedures evaluates the
decisions that were made the lab studies
the MRIs the CTS everything
and comes to a determination as to
whether this was a case
such as the doctor described where there
was was a hopeless case and and this
practitioner did the best he could
or this was a case of a Cavalier
physician exceeding his abilities his
training his scope of practice
and that's where
those investigations are also
confidential
they may well be reported to the board I
was involved many years ago with a
neurosurgeon in Dover who ultimately the
board lifted his license to practice
because he lied about a PhD in
linguistics in which he had never
completed his thesis had nothing to do
with his malpractice but it seemed to be
the safest way
to rid the institution and the state of
New Hampshire of
a doctor death
so
that's where the first line of defenses
is with the hospital credentials
committee and if that committee is made
up of people who see their job as to
protect their peers from further action
then the reports are not going to be
made to the Board of Medicine
then your next line of defense are that
every court clerk in the state in the
superior court system of which there are
10 is mandated by Statute
to notify
the Board of Medicine when a suit is
filed not when it's settled not when it
goes to verdict but when it is filed
but the Board of Medicine
does not involve itself in the discovery
process during the litigation the Board
of Medicine has no role in that
litigation other than to Simply know
that a claim was filed and then if a
verdict or settlement is paid on that
claim that is reported to the National
Practitioner Data Bank and maybe by the
Clerks of Court but I'm not even
persuaded that that always happens
thank you Dr uh yes and representative
Murphy
well thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for off the cuff coming up here and
volunteering your information so is it
your opinion from a legal perspective
what I'm hearing is that
and maybe I'm not this is not accurate
that it's not the statutes necessarily
in the state or federally that are
problem but it's the Homegrown problems
at local hospitals and that's practices
that's where it can first fall down
right is that if the credentialing
boards are not doing their and it's a
rotten job and nobody likes to be on the
credentials Committee in any institution
because it means you're
you're looking over your shoulder at
your colleagues and your peers who may
be your friends so my follow-up then is
that you haven't been involved in
credentialing and privileging committees
cutting back the Privileges of a
provider are sometimes done by the
provider himself or herself and
sometimes but less Often by the hospital
cutting back because you check the boxes
you know and they continue to practice
as they always have despite the fact
that their skill set may have
deteriorated is that you're well I I'm
not sure that that happens so much as
that privileges get limited but there is
no
uh ability of the consumer or people who
are not part of the team to know that
that has happened and that it implies
a criticism of the quality of care that
is being rendered
thank you representative Weber
thank you I'm probably splitting hairs
but I just want to go back to the issue
of settlements
clearly a settlement that happens in the
course of a court case is going to be
caught we hope it's going to be caught
by the court clerks and the reporting
system yes they're always they're always
informed but there's typically a
document filed called a neither party
docket marking and it says this the case
is resolved no judgment for either party
no further action on the same cause
meaning it's all gone and the court has
to know that so it can take the case off
its docket but my actual question if I
can finish it is the issue of
settlements well even like the one you
just said no further action but is is
there no further action because uh let
me ask it the way I was thinking of it
originally
um somebody believes they have a claim
they get an attorney the attorney sends
a demand letter to the physician or the
physician's Insurance whichever
comes first
and the insurance company looks at that
and says
we will pay X dollars to settle this
case right up front with no need to file
anything until recently all medical
malpractice insurance policies had a
clause called a consent to settle clause
and this insurance company most
insurance companies can settle claims
other than malpractice claims without
the authorization of their insured
because they see it as saving themselves
right and I get that but my question is
are those cases reported to anybody when
they get settled at that point okay the
insurers have the insurance the
statutory obligation under the law and
this law has been integrated into
Medicare and Medicaid and HIPAA so every
one of those Federal statutes has a
National Practitioner Data Bank
reporting requirement thank you I
appreciate that
representative soloway uh thank you uh
councilor nice to see you regards to Ms
Fiona
ire
um
you've indicated that the Superior
Courts are required to notify the Board
of Medicine if there is a complaint
filed is that correct yes
and is it conceivable that in some
states Boards of medicine could then be
proactive in pursuing their own
investigation
well I get the sense that the board is I
mean if there is a
a complaint that alleges you know clear
you know prescribed 180 Oxycontin to a
12 year old kid I imagine the board
would get involved in that pretty
quickly
um
but the board is well aware of the fact
that
most of the malpractice cases that get
tried in this state result in
defendant's verdicts
so
they're under no obligation to make an
immediate determination they
they are aware of it they keep an eye on
it but
um the board is not really the place
where
the rubbers hitting the road in terms of
actual malpractice it's in the
credentials committees
a quick follow-up so it is the board's
decision on how to proceed
in any Court notified case is that
correct
I yeah I would so I mean the
refer to an event
in the committee of Physicians of the
same specialty I'm not that familiar
with the board's uh procedures and I
think you have that witness here
um but yes but if your concern is that
things are happening too late and people
are being injured I just respectfully
suggest that
the concern about that should be with
Hospital credentials committee every
hospital has one they have to As a
matter of law and some of them just may
not be doing the job
thank you cousler thank you counselor if
you and I are speaking on the same
hypothetical which we might be
I wrote down when you said 20 to 21
terrible outcomes
um
we liberal arts people might call that
facts not an Evidence
laughs
I learn a lot from my lawyer friends
okay okay
um because that's part of the problem we
don't know in those 20 or 21 in the
hypotheticals that I think you and I are
agreeing with that we don't know the
level of which level that particular
which is why you vest in the Board of
Medicine the obligation to investigate
because that board is staffed with and
or has access to
Physicians practicing in the same
specialty who can sit down with those
records some of which will be this thick
I'm sure
and Wade through them and figure out
whether this was just a terrible case
that came out the way God meant it to or
it was malpractice that that's the job
of the Physicians
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair I have uh I have two different
questions the first one may just be a
yes no thing
um it is the National Practitioner Data
Bank accessible by the public no no all
right thank you and then the second one
I'm looking at a document that's not an
original Source it's called guidelines
for Hospital reporting and effective
September 9 2001. I there's none no
indication of who authored it but I'm
I'm just looking at it because it talks
about Hospital reporting
and it seems to me that
there there is no requirement or even
opportunity if this is literally
accurate for a credential board to
report to the Board of Medicine if they
simply have a concern
and and I'll I'll read to you what it
says reportable items uh related to
disciplinary discipline or adverse
action
if there's been a reduction a
restriction a suspension a revocation a
termination denial of Privileges and
then it's got some other things where it
says and these are not reportable
uh like failure to to do your medical
records properly failure to show up at
meetings and so so it seems to me that
there there may be a gap in the handoff
possibilities between a credential board
and the Board of Medicine if the
credential board
doesn't do a reduction
restriction suspension if they if they
if they're just concerned that there's
really no
mechanism for them to inform the Board
of Medicine am I am I missing that
there's no lack of mechanism the the
and I'm I'm looking for the statute I'm
aware of a statute that does
um
impose the obligation on peer review
committees and credentials committees to
report
um
to to the to the Board of Medicine
[Music]
um
this might be it 329 colon 1 double A
the practice of medicine is a privilege
granted by the people according to the
laws enacted by the legislature and not
a natural right in the interest of
public health safety and Welfare and to
protect the public from the
unprofessional improper incompetent
unlawful fraudulent and deceptive
practice of Medicine
it is necessary to provide laws and
rules to regulate the granting and
subsequent use of the privilege to
practice medicine and that leads into
the obligation of peer review committees
and credentialing committees to be alert
to and to report for investigation and
disciplinary proceedings where
appropriate by the Board of Medicine
so so are you aware of any time that a
credentialing board or peer review board
has uh reported to the Board of Medicine
when they simply are concerned as
opposed to having taken over action to
restrain the provider no nor would I be
because the only circumstance under
which I would be involved would be
probably as a representative of the
attorney as the attorney for the
physician before the board I have had
cases where uh peer review committees
have reported to the board and the board
has temporarily suspended the license of
that physician they have the authority
to do that for 10 days
and then they also have the authority to
go into court and seek an injunction
against further practice by that
physician
so there are there are statutory
opportunities for immediate intervention
in cases where there is perceived
threatened harm
so I'm just working on this scenario if
you don't know what you don't know if
the Board of Medicine is unaware that
there's a credentialing board out there
with some cons if poorly defined
concerns they're they're just not even
aware that there's a potential issue no
and I think a lot of times credentials
committees and peer review committees
will try and address these things
in-house because they can do so most
efficiently and perhaps with the least
damage to maybe an otherwise worthwhile
physician yeah and and then if I may
okay so
um in your earlier testimony you
mentioned that being on a credential
sport it can be
ugly nasty work because you're reviewing
the work of your friends and stuff and I
get that but I've worked in the real
world too and and I just wonder if there
are ever opportunities where somebody
may be on a credentialing board and uses
that power to go after an adversary a
competitor someone that looked at his
wife wrong or any any number of reasons
other than behaving in an A Way
displaying integrity and ethics have we
have you ever hard to imagine because
the people who are selected to sit on
these credentials committees are
regarded as
the cream not only with most knowledge
but High ethics all right and so you've
just never noticed it you're working the
other way I've never heard of it I mean
I might have read it in the John Grisham
novel but um I certainly have never
heard of it in practice I've never read
one of those so I just have a vivid
imagination thank you
anything else thank you counselor thank
you
the chair recognizes attorney Holly
Haynes
foreign
and you say you have written testimony
I do chairman uh I don't have it with me
though I put my thoughts together for
this committee meeting this weekend and
you have written testimonies I will
submit it that's halfway home it is
halfway yeah I promise that I will email
it to you today by the end of business
representative Edward says in fact it's
all the way home
so thank you very much chairman for
competing this hearing and for allowing
me to testify my name is Holly Haines
I'm an attorney at Abramson Brown and
Dugan in Manchester New Hampshire and I
represent patients who have been harmed
by medical errors and many who have been
harmed by physicians who had committed
numerous medical errors in the past and
had not been disciplined
this is a really important committee I'm
glad that you're convening it I think
there are a lot of different issues that
need to be addressed the purpose of the
Board of Medicine is you
we were discussing earlier is the first
and foremost it's to protect the
Integrity of the profession it's to make
sure that doctors are practicing
medicine safely
the second is
to protect the public and to do that
you need to have transparency which is
what this committee is about
by disclosing both complaints or
malpractice payments that are made on
behalf of a physician and also claims
that are brought against them or if
discipline is imposed I want to address
just a couple of points that were made
by prior speakers if I may
um
first Dr Conway
um whose testimony was excellent uh said
that if the Board of Medicine or the
medical review subcommittee does not
hear it as a board the board can't do
anything about it
um as this committee probably knows from
the Boston Globe Spotlight article
attorney Chuck Douglas did report this
to the board in 2018
and the board had full information about
that at that time and could have
conducted an investigation the board was
presented I believe with medical records
for many of the patients as well
a second question that was asked was
whether or not the existence of a
non-disclosure agreement in a settlement
agreement May prohibit or limit what the
board can do our office was actively
involved in legislation in 2003 it's RSA
507 E3
again
sure
um this is about whether or not nda's uh
limit what the board can do could you
cite the reference again please it's RSA
507e3
thank you and that statute prohibits
confidential settlements from preventing
people from reporting to the Board of
Medicine it makes sure that all
confidential settlements can be reported
to the Board of Medicine
um
with regard to it not being the statutes
that are the problem that it's the
hospital committees that are the problem
I'm not going to disagree at all with
attorney vanders and that it the
hospital committees are a problem
um in this state I think they should be
more aggressive with disciplining
their own as well but I do believe that
there are significant problems with our
statutes and I will lay those out in
my written testimony for you that you
will have later but the biggest problem
that I think we have is that the statute
itself is permissive for the Board of
Medicine everything for the Board of
Medicine is permissive the statute
mandates that the Superior Court shall
report actions to the board the statute
mandates that insurers shall report
payments to the board the statute
mandates that hospitals and
credentialing committees shall report
adverse action and discipline to the
board but
the statute says that
and the statute is uh 329.17 and 329 18.
the board May undertake disciplinary
proceedings the board May undertake
non-disciplinary remedial measures
um every provision related to what the
Board of Medicine does is
permissive but everything for every
other reporting entity in the state of
New Hampshire is mandatory I submit that
a simple change to the statute could be
to make it mandatory as opposed to
permissive that the Board of Medicine
shall conduct disciplinary proceedings
shall conduct formal investigations
shall
undertake non-disciplinary remedial
proceedings when appropriate it doesn't
change any of the statutory Provisions
for the reasons that discipline can or
can be imposed and it's a very simple
fix to the statute that I suggest
would be easily done and it would give
the Board of Medicine more Authority it
would allow there to be more oversight
over the practice of medicine and I
suspect and respectfully submit that
more discipline would be imposed and
would be public for the public
um with regard to the transparency issue
that I know prompted this committee to
be formed
there were concerns because of
Massachusetts Board of Medicine reports
medical malpractice payments that have
been made whereas the New Hampshire
Board of Medicine does not
you've heard from several people that
the reporting of payments made is
mandated by the National Practitioner
Data Bank under federal law
I submit that the New Hampshire Board of
Medicine could make their website
identical to Massachusetts
by simply
go into the National Practitioner Data
Bank and taking the data of malpractice
payments and putting it on the licensing
form I realize that would be onerous and
quite a task because there are 8 700
licensed physicians in New Hampshire but
each time a physician renews their
license the board must go to the
National Practitioner Data Bank anyhow
they could go at renewal and update each
Physician's licensing profile to include
that information no patient names would
be included no allegations of
malpractice would be there there
wouldn't be any privacy concerns and
since physician licenses are renewed in
six year Cycles six years from now
hopefully our website would be up to
date with public information have the
same information that Massachusetts has
um
some other points that were made earlier
I must disagree with uh my colleague
attorney Vander zanden in her answer to
representative solway's question
I think the Board of Medicine could be
proactive to do more I they certainly
should be proactive to do more when they
receive a complaint from the federal
from the Superior Court when it is
reported to them they should conduct an
investigation they should have the
statutory authority to do that and they
should be mandatory right now they have
the permissive authority to do that
that's one of the things that should be
mandatory that should trigger an
investigation and they should be given
the authority to hire appropriate
experts to conduct that investigation
our office I know there are always
concerns about
um frivolous malpractice claims a
malpractice crisis we've heard this for
decades
our office does almost exclusively
medical malpractice we do some personal
injury actions but by and large 95
percent of our practices medical
malpractice I looked at the recent data
our last year of reporting we compile
our data once a year
um so from June 2020 to June 2021
we received on average 150 calls or
emails asking do I have a case
that is about 1800 a year
of those
the vast majority are not meritorious at
all we probably request medical records
in one out of 10 of those maybe 15 out
of the 150 a month those we have
reviewed by a medical expert in the
specialty that the person is complaining
about and if our medical expert supports
a claim
then we file suit if our medical expert
does not support a claim we explain that
to the patient and we decline the case
we probably file suit in one to two of
the ones that we look at per month it is
less than one percent of the intakes to
our office that actually get filed in
Superior Court so I know there are a lot
of um
concerns about frivolous claims but I
would submit to you that attorneys in
New Hampshire and I know there has been
past testimony at the legislature there
aren't frivolous claims in New Hampshire
that are brought because they're so cost
prohibitive to bring
um for a plaintiff to hire medical
experts to pursue that to pay for their
medical records Imaging testing uh
the costs are exorbitant and they are
not going to take a chance on
losing as you heard um and this is one
of the other points that I would just
like to clarify the vast majority of
malpractice cases in New Hampshire that
go to trial and that's the specific
that's the most important part our
defense verdicts but the vast majority
of malpractice cases that are filed in
Superior Court do not ever see a trial
they don't ever see a courtroom because
they are resolved out of court
because they are meritorious claims so
the vast majority of cases filed in
Superior Court are meritorious and I
would submit I know people have concerns
I've heard some concerns expressed that
um
maybe an insurer made a payment because
it's a nuisance payment they don't want
to pay the exorbitant costs of taking
the case to trial they don't want to pay
their own experts so they make a
settlement
to pay a nuisance cost and that's going
to be reported to the National
Practitioner Data Bank
I understand that that's a concern but I
would submit that making the statute
mandatory for board disciplined
investigations
in all of the situations where reporting
is already mandatory in the superior
court if it's been filed in the Superior
Court the case has to have been vetted
already by a medical expert attorneys
have their own professional
responsibility not to file mer uh
frivolous claims
that's one of the rules that we're
subject to it has already been vetted if
and insurer the statute requires that
insurance companies anytime they set a
reserve in a case meaning anytime there
they receive a report of an injury to a
patient by Medical Practice if they set
a reserve and a case they have to report
it to the Board of Medicine
if an insurance company is setting a
reserve in a case it meets the insurance
company has had the claim reviewed by a
medical expert already in that specialty
likewise in the case of hospitals and
credentialing committees if they report
an action they have reviewed it by
medical experts or at least Physicians
within their hospital so all of these
cases where the reporting is already
mandatory to the board I submit the
investigation disciplinary process by
the board should be mandatory as well
because all of those have at least
passed an initial vetting of being
reviewed by a medical expert those are
not frivolous claims they are not the
1800 people who call their office or
email their office those are the one or
two that had
um Merit after being vetted by medical
experts to the point that they got filed
in court the vast majority would never
um
get to that point
and
I think that was the last point that I
wanted to address on the other um
that the other attorneys had made and
I'm happy to answer questions does
anybody have a question for attorney
Haynes representative Weber
I'd just like to see if we could
either substantiate or dismiss the
question of the nuisance payments
are you is is there any way of of
figuring out
I mean I love the statistics you've
given us because it puts the issues into
a far more clear perspective for me and
I'm wondering if there is any way of
getting at the same kind of clarity
with respect to the oh somebody just
gets paid forty thousand dollars to go
away
um which I certainly have seen in the
case of um
um
insurance claims with respect to
building losses and things like that but
I I have no idea
how prevalent that is or or how often
that happens in the medical malpractice
case so I don't know whether that's
something we ought to think about or not
and I wonder what your perspective on
those is because if if it's not if it
doesn't happen we don't have to worry
about it anymore
I suspect that it does happen I don't
think that I'm the appropriate person to
answer that question I know that there
are multiple defense attorneys in the
room who who defend our cases okay who
may be able to better speak to that okay
thank you
representative Edwards uh uh thank you
so
um I I what you said makes perfect sense
that you would have an internal vetting
process that requires a medical review
before you decide whether or not the
case had Merit was worthy of pursuit
uh but I assume two things and maybe you
could
explode either or both of them I I
assume that um that that that internal
medical vetting is just good legal
practice and is not required in order to
be able to file a suit so there's
there's you're not you're not required
to do that it just makes sense to do
that and and the other assumption would
be that there may be some uh young
attorneys out there with a shingle that
they've hung that don't yet have a
developed practice to include a medical
review who could file
a malpractice suit without the due
diligence that your firm puts into it
what how do you deal with those two kind
of assumptions so the first
I respectfully believe is incorrect
um there are statutory requirements to
file a malpractice suit in New Hampshire
and the statute requires
um an expert witness to support each of
the elements of a claim and the statute
has four specific elements so in order
to file a claim an attorney would have a
professional obligation to have a
medical expert that can support this
does that mean that a pro se litigant
would not I don't know that there there
may be and I believe that there are some
prosely litigants who do file claims
on their own behalf and may not have
medical experts I know that some have
been dismissed
could a young attorney or would a young
attorney do that I would hope that they
don't because there are statutory
requirements and I would hope that they
would call
our office or refer the case to our
office or not try to get and delve into
an area that they don't have experience
with do you have the citation of the
statute at hand
uh yes it's RSA
507e4 I believe that has the elements of
the claim
yeah you you would want to look the
medical injury statute the chapters RSA
507e thank you representative Ed would
you want to follow up yes and thank you
for the education I I have to admit I've
not read every RSA uh so I appreciate
the education the um okay so so because
you're doing the medical vetting
in-house it seems to me like
um you're you're you have an implicit
argument that that may there may be
sufficient due diligence just on the
basis of your internal work that would
be sufficient for us to do public
reporting that a malpractice suit has
been filed at this point we're not the
Board of Medicine is not reporting those
um but but
would it is it wrong of me to think that
you're implying that you your firms are
doing enough work that we should it
should be a able to be substantiated as
reportable eye action
just the seat filing of the suit itself
I think the fact that a suit has been
filed could absolutely be reported or
absolutely should be reported and the
fact that a suit has been filed it's
already public record in the Superior
Court
okay so
um I want to get to the permissive part
changing maze the shells and um are you
familiar with like the main mass or
Vermont statutes would would the
changing our maze the shells make us
very much like the surrounding states or
or would we be getting into a a more
rigid environment than they're in I do
not know I haven't looked at any of
those State statutes all right then you
have a homework assignment but no I'm
kidding but thank you
any other questions
thank you counselor appreciate
chair recognizes Sean mcgorry
got the red button early
I want to thank everybody for having
this hearing
my name is Sean mcgorry I'm not an
attorney
I am not a physician I don't work at a
hospital I represent my sister who
could possibly be tragic case number 22
who died at the hands of Yvonne barabo
we found out some years after her
surgery that he had been suspended the
summer before her surgery
if she had that information
she would not have gone forward with the
surgery she was nervous about the
surgery to begin with
but without proper information how can a
patient give consent
for that surgeon to do surgery if they
don't have the information
to me
the Board of Medicine Catholic Medical
Center failed my sister
because the information is not reported
she was not able to make an informed
decision about who was going to perform
surgery
as a family we made a decision that we
were not going to file a lawsuit because
we felt as though with open heart
surgery there is a human element to that
surgery that things can go wrong
had we had that information
perhaps our decision would have been
different
I'm not looking to get involved in any
lawsuits I'm not looking to gain any
monetary settlement from this what I'm
looking for is I'm looking to hold the
hospital responsible for failing to
provide the information and to protect
my sister
she had the surgery
we got a call the next morning that
something had gone wrong
the afternoon of the surgery Yvonne
barabow told us that the surgery went
great and he finished it in almost
record time
then there was an incident of
catastrophic brain swelling and I will
remember that word until the day I die
catastrophic brain swelling which they
normally only see with a head trauma
she never came out of the anesthesia she
never regained consciousness
we my brother actually questioned it
several hours after the surgery because
she had already had one valve
replacement performed
and she was not responding to any
touches any speech anything else hours
after the surgery
so on Wednesday after her surgery my 87
year old mother had to watch for two
minutes to see if her daughter's chest
would rise on its own
which it didn't
that is negligence on the part of the
hospital the doctor and they all failed
my sister because they didn't want to
share that information they could have
shared that information
she should have been made aware that he
had been suspended
if I'm not mistaken he was on limited
privileges at the time of my sister's
surgery
she was not made aware of that
so I'm not talking about
lawsuits I'm not talking about anything
that we can talk about insurance
companies all we want
as a manager of a business if I have an
employee who gets hurt yet had a prior
injury
the workers comp insurance can settle
and I have no say why are doctor's any
different
we're talking about human beings
we're not talking about hospitals we're
not talking about insurance companies my
sister is a human being who's not here
anymore
because we don't have the transparency
in the state of New Hampshire
I personally would like to thank the
Boston Globe for bringing this
information forth because clearly none
of the media agencies in New Hampshire
did
and again I just think that's
reprehensible that nobody ever looked
into this
and to call them tragic outcomes
to me dismisses what really happened
there weren't tragic outcomes
there were negligence on the part of the
doctor that resulted in people's deaths
let's break it down to what it is it's
not a tragic outcome people died
because we aren't transparent in the
state of New Hampshire
if I'm not mistaken we report the
disciplinary records of police officers
don't we
why are doctors held
to a higher level that they don't need
that
that's all I have
should anybody have a question would you
take one absolutely committee anyone
yeah
thank you for your testimony thank you
the chair recognizes Dr Emily Baker from
the Board of Medicine
pass the first test
I'm Emily Baker I'm the current
president of the Board of Medicine
I've been a full-time practicing
obstetrician in our state for 29 years
and the pleasure of serving women and
their families
I've been the Board of Medicine for
eight years
serving the citizens of New Hampshire
the board is comprised of medical
doctors osteopaths physician assistant
and public members the members are very
important to us
the board knows I know that it's my
primary responsibility to Serve and
Protect the citizens of New Hampshire
there is not a meeting
that goes by where somebody doesn't say
out loud
my role here is to protect the citizens
of New Hampshire
so when it's been very difficult for us
me board hasn't met yet so
since the globe articles
because we do take it seriously and have
the press and comments made making the
assumption that we don't has been hard
because we do take it very seriously and
we do investigate the board sees
everything
that we get
but if we don't see something we can't
act on it we can't evaluate it
we did not see 20 of 21 of the things on
the board of Registration of Medicine
and Mass
so that's a small thing but just letting
you know as an example that was not a
piece of information that we had that we
could act on
I'm not here to talk about specifics
because I can't disclose
certainly things that were held in
confidentiality
one of the a lot of this stuff has been
brought up
with you know am I prepared stuff that's
already been spoken about
yeah I have this I'm bad about my the my
voice doesn't carry very well so
it is always a problem
um one of the things that just got
brought up about making the assumption
that the board does not take on cases
that are in process of tort
when we see a
case coming and we see all the lawsuits
we don't hold back on starting our own
investigation to letting the tort
process go on and that's a change that
happened during my few years on the
board for some time we would say yep
it's going to be we're sorry it could be
prejudicial to you the doctor if we do
ours because if we take action that's
going to impact on your tort process we
don't do that
we now look at them we do start
investigating even before the it's run
through because it takes years
and years to go through the legal
process claim to be made you know
Discovery testimony so it takes a long
time so we're no longer waiting you just
have to get started
um so that's one one piece I wanted why
not
um
the other thing
briefly take a second because one of the
things that got brought up in all this
was how does New Hampshire compare so
the Federation of State Medical boards
is the National Organization it does a
lot for us it's part of the the public
data banks it does
um licensing examinations for residents
for um students
but it also pays attention to everything
each one of the boards does right
so I went to their most recent document
about looking what all of the
individuals boards do and then this can
take a second to read one of the things
that they ended up concluding
the tremendous sorry variation in
statutory funding judicial
administrative and Geographic
environments from state to state
precludes any meaningful comparative
reporting of disciplinary statistics by
state
and we're all different and so
I think it's going to be very important
and I think the FSNB is actually a very
good resource because there are
documents that say this is what Arizona
does this is what New Hampshire does so
I can get it for you
those documents exist and that's what
the fsmv can provide for you
um
uh let's see the the most the
the most recent discussion about having
the Torah process inform what we should
report
shall report the
we
do have our experts and we look at
everything and act on cases and it makes
me feel a little nervous having the tort
process be what drives the valuations of
Physicians and you've already brought up
some of the questions about
you know
um
professionalism lawyers to lawyers I
mean I
I grew up in family lawyers
my dad's a federal judge so I understand
a lot of this and I don't I'm not
frightened by a large legal system but I
want to have us at least stop and think
about do how much do we want to divest
to the legal process in terms of
preparing what we're going to do for
evaluating our licensees
you brought up a point about licenses
that's one of the
giving a license to a licensee is one of
the things that we spend a lot of time
on
we get all of the licenses where there's
been any sort of deviation failed an
exam have a lawsuit and we spend a bunch
of time talking about that so because if
you once you let them in
so we're very careful about that and we
don't give everybody a license
and we spent a long time on all these
investigations that get started so our
days we're they're all day long and we
evaluate everything that's brought to us
and
very few end up being severe enough for
discipline that's true for all states
because
a lot of stuff comes in they didn't have
a billing the doctor was mean to me some
things are serious but it's the doctor
comes and he says to us
I made a mistake
and then
does that person go to discipline and
never learn from that mistake because
now they're patients don't trust them
anymore so
and you
I guess it's probably easier for me to
take questions from you
representative Weber
thank you Mr chair and thank you very
much for your testimony here today
um
I'm
trying increasingly dividing things into
several different strands one of which
is when do we report publicly
but the other strand is when do we start
to investigate
and what I think I want to ask other
than um
is the fsmd is that a publicly available
resource oh absolutely and if you would
give us the site for example this would
be really helpful
um
is going back to the suggestion made
earlier that we change May investigate
to shall investigate
and I wonder what your opinion is on
that change from the perspective of
somebody on the board and then further I
wonder if we change that may to shall if
you thought that would impact the
um personnel and resources employed by
the board and by how much yeah
um one thing I'd say is
everything that comes in
gets investigated
it may be the physician investigator and
the oplc investigator who looks and says
this doesn't meet criteria for being
evaluated or this was
a billing question but that still comes
to us we see
everything all the complaints that come
in all the claims made
it comes to us it and we do undertake
an investigation but not everybody comes
to the place of having discipline for
example
um and I'm kind of hard to understand
what that's which would mean if the
notion is we have to have a full
investigation right we don't have the
resources to have hearings for all of
these complaints for example that we
just don't we get hundreds and hundreds
of complaints and we can't
so if they're all if they were all
egregious they would all get hearings
absolutely but most things that come in
don't come to hearing
which hearings take us half a day
sometimes two days
if it's if it's an egregious event we
it's it's sort of like having a trial
and we abrogate give up
as much as a couple of days to these so
if that's the hope is that we would
investigate to the extent of having a
hearing
that we don't have resources for that
and a lot of it doesn't make sense could
I clarify Mr yes no I just it I thought
I was hearing earlier on that there are
cases that are reported to the Board of
Medicine which are either just put on
hold pending
something else happening as in the case
of a tort and and now I've been told no
they don't get put on hold so what I'm
if what I'm hearing for you which is
that every single complaint
gets looked at at a minimum by an
investigator who determines no there is
no
whatever happened here it was not
something that is a subject for
discipline from the Board of Medicine
um
what does that mean no
um then then that's fine we don't need
to change anything I I want to get us to
the point where
everything that comes in and what I
think I'm hearing you saying is that
everything that comes in gets reviewed
and then it gets sorted into the pile of
this is just a billing complaint this is
the doctor's manner was not what I would
have liked it to be or whatever
all the way through to a full hearing I
I wanted to make it clear that I'm not
in any way asking for a full Hearing in
every case because it's not warranted by
any case
so
I guess the corollary question is if we
changed May investigate to shall
investigate not not hold a hearing but
just investigate
uh in the statutes would that be of your
problem for you
because it sounds like that's what
you're doing now I mean everything that
comes in gets investigated
physician investigator or goes to the
medical review subcommittee and you know
your but no further action that comes to
us too right we see the no further
actions and then we make a decision of
this is a disciplinary tract
or can this be managed not in a
disciplinary way and we tell the doctor
okay this is what we learned and
and give them point you know and then
that gets in their file and if it comes
up again it's in their file
so you still didn't tell me how you felt
about changing made a shell
um
I guess it so long as As
the understanding of shall investigate
is understanding that the pro like what
we're doing right and if the public says
or legislatures by you they shall
investigate I need you to do to this
degree
and if it's just a matter of you guys
decide what the level of Investigation
is well then it
doesn't make any difference it's what we
do
thank you
any other questions for Dr Baker
representative Murphy thank you and
thank you for the testimony I had two
questions one is is this too cold for
you okay because these guys will be hot
and then I'll be in trouble they wanted
to make sure
um
I think we've heard a lot today about
what I don't know I don't know I can't
act on information I don't have already
in the hospital we have credentialing
and privileging committees they
established on them right they establish
that you have I always looked at it as
the credentials say that you have a
medical license but you're only
privileged to do X
it's analogous to I have a pilot's
license but your privilege is that you
can only find a Cessna not a 747.
we have you know m m committees
we have quality review we have a lot of
internal committees at the local level
but somehow it seems like if somebody is
discovered or you know somebody is not
practicing up to speed
there there seems to be that that
information is somehow not available to
the Board of Medicine who ultimately
provides the license and as you said
provides some assurances to the public
that safety is going to be assured at
that organization
so I I guess what I'm asking is
can you suggest or do you have
suggestions or thoughts about what is
necessary whether it's legislative or
not that Bridges the gap between the
local disciplinary and investigation and
evaluation and that which is the board
of medicines purview to provide them
with a medicine a medical license
um
I'm not sure with some statute now but I
think hospitals are expected to report
these and when we see them then we're
able to investigate that so I think
if there's not a statute that says
hospitals need to report what happens on
on their credentials committees than it
should be now you mentioned Eminem that
is a whole separate carve out and that's
really what the whole point of that is
to improve care for the public and not
have that be discoverable
the um
so surely hospitals should be expected
to report actions the other thing that's
happened in the last
several years nationally is the Joint
Commission has been very prescriptive
about processes for evaluating of
Physicians where you have to do
professional practice evaluations and so
hospitals that are
accredited by The Joint Commission have
these processes not not every hospital
in the state of New Hampshire
is a joint commission hospital and so
again I don't know what the regulations
or statutes are for the not those
hospitals
is it detailed enough to make it of the
same sort of level of scrutiny as The
Joint Commission hospitals
just a quick follow-up um so I guess my
question would be then is there
something that you would want to have
available to you so that you could fully
and safely and effectively evaluate you
know providers
um I think we would be
helped by having
a greater ability to get experts not
necessarily on our state right now it's
New Hampshire and so we're really Frugal
and the majority of evaluations we get
are done by either the medical review
subcommittee or we ask pro bono a
physician in the state to help us
that works great the majority of the
time but you know it's a small state
everybody knows each other right and
sometimes if
and we're going to work with the oplc on
that they're they've been great about
that but I think having more resources
to be able to
get experts outside because if like some
cases it'll run if you've got two of
these guys in the state you can't have
somebody within the state
provide you with with expert support for
evaluating their competency
that would be that would be helpful I
mean part of it's executive in terms of
how much funds are distributed that's no
small piece of it because you can only
have so many Resources with the money
that that you're given but from a
legislative standpoint
deciding when you look and we all look I
guess and see what the other states do
what do we want to look like then that
would be a matter of Statute and I don't
think there's nobody who thinks that
there should be
silence over this we care about the the
patient we care about our citizens and
if something needs to get reported
it should be reported
thank you
representative Edwards uh thank you Dr
Baker I
um as I look at the the statute section
329 colon 18
paragraph one or I uh
representative Weber actually taught me
this years ago that you should go into
the statute to see if something's
defined and I think the definition of
Investigations is loose enough there
it's formal or informal that that I I
don't know I made a shall would would
tie your hands much
um but I don't I don't want to jump to
that conclusion but
um if if there are
um
how did you react
um when you heard the argument that that
this is too permissive and we should be
looking to change maze to shall says are
are there are there a number of maze in
here that that you think would be good
contenders for being changed to show
um
but only when I remember offhand is the
shall investigate
in it enough if you guys remember the
ones that she said
I I assume you have
um a Consulting attorney that works with
the board or not we have our boards we
have a board attorney for us
there's
um the oplc has an attorney but we have
a attorney who sits with us and if I
turn I say could you help me understand
this statute our rules and regulations
permission of the chair I think I'd like
to ask for the board to come back and
say sure which of are there May's in
here that you think should be shells or
or something like that I think that
might be useful and we don't have a
whole lot of time for that because we're
supposed to be done in three months or
three weeks so are you um yeah I'm I'm
you're okay with that yeah okay the in
under the uh the board duties I skimmed
it to see if the board members are
compensated no well so we get lunch so
so it's you're you're volunteers and
you're putting in a lot of time
um do you do you know if that comes with
it a um a legal liability standard if
you guys don't perform your job properly
could could you be sued as being a
member of the board that that didn't do
what they were supposed to I
don't know the answer to that
it's a little scary that you're asking
any
I think you should be protected I mean
even me on a homeowner's board we have
insurance to keep us from being
personally liable for anything that the
board May mess up and so I was just
curious if we needed to make sure you
all were protected because as volunteers
providing a valuable service and you're
all very expensive people uh and you're
donating your time I would just want to
make sure that you personally as board
members would not be subject to you know
Financial liability for uh much
appreciated yeah that's where I was
coming from
um
a typical so you're the you're you've
been
um the president of the board for a few
years now I thank you sir and this is I
took over Dr Conway's term when he went
to be the physician investigator I had a
previous stint as being president four
or five years ago okay so where I'm
going with that is you would know by now
just how time consuming this is for you
as the president and maybe what some of
the other board members could you could
you tell us about the time commitment
that the board spends on this in a
voluntary role yeah sure
um the board meetings themselves are a
full day in Concord we generally start
at eight and we can and as late as eight
if we've had a hearing and then need to
because all our business gets done we
have to get all the business done even
if there hasn't been here for a month
per year we meet once a month once a
month and you're we have homework
basically to do which is reading all of
the documents that are going to be acted
on
and the amount of time it takes to read
that it varies a little bit but usually
on that weekend I spend probably eight
hours
eight to ten hours reading those
so would it be fair to say that you're
committed to you know between 10 and 20
hours a month sort of minimum
yeah especially sort of doing extra
board president things yeah okay so I'm
I'm done with my questions I just want
to thank you for your volunteer status
and all that you do for the state I
appreciate it thank you anything else
for Dr Baker
your testimony uh I'm willing to as you
pointed up come back and if you wanted
to do more of the xiaomi so I don't have
to walk again I left a batch of my cards
you can take one if if you wish it's my
second one
values and showers
I'll do whatever you want
okay
fantastic
thank you so much for your testimony oh
you're welcome thank you anything from
attorney Williams
this has been a very educational
afternoon I do want to catch up with
representative Edwards afterwards just
to to just give him a little bit of
briefing on the 99d coverage for both
defense indemnification for State actors
so it applies not only to individuals
who would be serving On The Board of
Medicine but anybody in an executive
branch function acting under Colorado
state law under their normal functions
and duties there are limitations you
can't emit crimes and be covered but if
it's otherwise there is to the state and
I know attorney Douglas osterhoud has
even more refined a couple of other
statutes that does cover for the
concerns that you raised regarding
identification and protection for Dr
Baker and folks similarly situated who
volunteer in the capacity of acting on
behalf of the state
thank you attorney Williams anything
further
anything from attorney Austin
no I think attorney Williams covered
what I was going to add that a lot of
the practice acts do have their own
statutory carve-outs that protect and
indemnify individuals acting in good
faith
let me ask any of the attorneys here to
what degree does 91a prevent the
committee from
doing anything more than one person
talking to no more than 50 percent minus
in other words can we have a discussion
on today
with all of us on board
I'm gonna I'm gonna defer to represent
Weber on this issue because I think we
we think alike on this subject matter
under coverage of 99 91a
well I guess I'm not really
understanding the question we're here in
a notice meeting so we can discuss
anything are you talking about
discussing amongst ourselves outside of
a notice meeting
then we're covered by 91a and if it's
more than half of us and it's not a
political caucus
and it's not an exception somewhere we
can't do it I was looking for the
exception somewhere
not that I know of but I mean
okay I'm not the best
prepared to answer that because
I only know the things that have come up
that I've gotten stuck with I was
looking for and I don't remember how
many people there are in this committee
but there is certainly a number of
people on this committee who are not
here today so yeah
um I was looking for the process towards
the content the agenda of our next
meeting primarily
I don't think when you're talking about
stuff that were that we're not going to
vote on or make decisions on things like
when we're going to meet
um attached our
3987 pages of material to you for you to
review before our next meeting or
I have certain concerns that I want you
to think about are things that we have
always traditionally rightly or wrongly
send out in advance so that people can
read them not while they're sitting at
the table but before so that they can
and and generally when we do that
whoever sends them reminds everybody not
to discuss them just to look at them and
bring any
comments they have okay yeah that's what
I was looking for so then I think we can
do that anyone else with anything before
we adjourn
there was one question I wanted to ask
somebody but I do I can do that
afterwards Rover well you're focusing on
an agenda I wanted to ask a question
related to the calculation of medical
malpractice premiums and whether or not
increased disclosures
public disclosures may have a direct
impact on increasing medical liability
insurance costs
I think the board of insurance would
answer I think
my thought on that would be that that's
a really good question but it's outside
of the competence of this committee and
it's something that should be examined
in the con in the context of any
legislation that would be filed to
require disclosure
and that would mean that it could be
considered by
presumably somebody on the Commerce
Committee who deals with insurance
premiums and that kind of thing but that
really wasn't our mandate our mandate
was to talk about
transparency not not the effect on
insurance premiums
the word homework has been invoked more
than once and we've just added to your
list thank you we're finished
thank you
we're in disagreement about that but I I
know I understand